me we are away to the races all
right okay so um Connolly he it's an
absolute honor to meet you in real life
for the second time actually that you
know to interview you in real life uh
you've been on the show many times now
actually so we we of course interviewed
you about alignment and safety that then
you were a co-interviewer with Jeff
Hawkins and with Carl freston and uh
yeah it's just amazing to actually have
all of the expensive video equipment and
to do high quality recording with you so
uh yeah welcome to mlst well I'm so glad
to be here uh what a way we've come
well I was just going to say that so now
Conor is the CEO of conjecture and I
wouldn't I mean I wouldn't have been
able to imagine this a couple of years
ago I mean you really had the foresight
to see how important this technology is
and Walid subur recently came on the
show and he admitted that he was wrong
about large language models respect to
respect to my man yeah I mean at least
at least he has the the humility and you
know not to misrepresent him he still
says that there are limitations with
semantics and pragmatics but
let's not ignore the success of large
language models
absolutely yeah we did that first video
which has been watched 150 000 times now
and um even at the time people said it
was really cool that we were showing
both both views you know the the extreme
end of both ends and I think it's fair
to say that you've come out on top on
that particularly well well well yeah
many such cases
yeah well you know the thing was I was
convinced that you were Fooled by
Randomness because the first version of
gpt3
um to me it was obvious that it was just
kind of pattern matching and there are
so many examples you were citing of no
no Tim wake up it's really reasoning
it's really doing something interesting
here and
there are many different ways of coming
at this I think
do you remember you get you gave us
secret access to the apis that we were
we were using the API through this kind
of rubbish interface that I think one of
your friends had made or something or
maybe you've made it and part of part of
the magic of gbt3 is the interface and
and how how it's presented to you as
well so there's a bit of that when it
went to DaVinci 2 that was a huge kind
of psychological shift for me I was
actually thinking oh my God and also I
started to trust it in a weird way and I
mean a lot of this is still being Fooled
by Randomness like
um I'm I'm kind of cherry picking
without realizing that
in many cases I do trust the output
especially in the part of it is me
learning how to use the model
so when I'm saying here's some text
summarize it for me
it it basically it never makes any
mistakes if I'm saying tell me about
this thing that you know about then it's
more likely to hallucinate
I mean what how do you think about it
yeah so I I think it's going to bring up
the idea of the interface and how
important that is to interact with the
model I think one of the fundamental
differences when I first saw the model
compared to a lot of other people when
they first saw the model
is it gbd is this terrible interface
problem still has this problem it's
gotten better where you're like okay you
have this Grand great AI system most
powerful AI system ever built and then
you click on the link and you get a
white text box and text box like what
the what am I supposed to do with
this like you know you type in some
stuff you click a button and maybe
output something is like sort of
interesting or maybe not or who knows
whatever and then you're like okay and
then you just kind of don't give it a
second thought and so what was different
for me is that you know after having
worked with these systems way more and
having seen people who are very good at
prompting it and spent hours hundreds
and thousands of hours prompting these
models and like them showing me what
these things could do and also you know
me just kind of having um work with the
previous generational models and just
have you know drawing a straight line on
the curve being like okay well I saw
gpt2 you know 100 m and I was pretty
familiar with what that could do and
then I saw the straight line of how just
you know just went straight to gpd3 like
just reliably things that didn't work
with smaller model some of them started
working with larger models some of them
started working with even larger models
some of them started working Etc so I
just kind of like extrapolated
it was always obviously like GT3 had any
problems and there was many ways to
improve it like a lot sometimes people
ask me Conor you know track gbt came out
wow it's so crazy it's so good has this
updated you're like believe some like AI
or something like no it was super
predictable like just draw a line bro
yeah just just the draw straight line
it's like
the interesting thing about GPT is in my
impression at least is that it can't
really do actually anything that gpt3
couldn't already do it just does it
really reliably and it has a better
interface because it has like the like
chat interface which is like more
natural for humans but like most of the
actual tasks that you ask chat GPT can
do like maybe not GB3 but like DaVinci
or like DaVinci 2 could do if you're
good at prompting so
in that sense it wasn't a huge advance
in capability so much as an advanced
interface an Advan advanced in a way to
make it more reliable and kind of show
the things that you could have already
seen if you're already pretty deep into
it so I see like chapter EPT and DaVinci
2 and such as like just like like
um reliability improvements just
engineering quote unquote yeah I mean
we've crossed the threshold though and
we'll get into the rlhf in in a bit but
I think something like a million people
use chat GPT in the first five days
which from a product Market fit point of
view is better than any other Tech
startup ever so everyone is signing on
to it now and it's a little bit like
when the World Wide Web came out nobody
understood that it was going to change
the world until it did yeah so there's a
bit of that I I agree with you that
there is a huge technical component to
knowing how to prompt it I've been doing
it probably for about six months now
with DaVinci 2. I use it for absolutely
every single component of my life I
always have about 20 tabs open and the
thing is
there are so many domain-specific
applications for language models but I
prefer just being in the playground and
on openai
um I honestly I can't even tell you how
many things I use it for like
understanding code writing code I mean
yesterday I got it to write me a bite a
byte pairing code of in C sharp so I
just copied the python code and I said
you know translate this into C sharp
and when there are errors I just paste
the errors in and I say oh it's giving
me this problem this is the state of the
array so the hash table has these values
in
um you know can you explain this step by
step can you fix it what's the problem
what's the time complexity it's just
unreal
general intelligence is a great product
well I mean the thing is like you can
say that oh it's just information
retrieval which just this is just that
but you know like in a way people have
got to wake up that it is a receding
Horizon and I have to admit that if you
can use it for literally anything the
yeah don't get me wrong there are gaps
but you fill in the gaps because if you
misunderstand something or it does
something I'm trying not to use
anthropomorphic language I understand
we'll talk about that in a minute but
um as an extension to my own cognitive
apparatus it's it's revolutionary yep I
I agree it's an incredibly useful
product it's you can do incredibly
useful things with it it's reach kind of
like a reliability Horizons only going
to increase it's like things you can't
do sure I could tell you like several
I've tested in these models and I know a
bunch of things they can't currently do
but they can't at least you reliably at
all but
I think yeah it's like obvious these
things can do incredibly useful things
they you know these aren't hard-coded
capabilities these are General
capabilities it picked up from training
data it can it can you know reply to
extremely free form kind of inputs and
like it can be creative and flexible and
do all these kind of things sure all
these things have limitations but I mean
you know you know my feelings on this
it's just pretty obvious to me that this
is just my crazy prediction the crazy
prediction I have or what will happen in
the future people ask me Connor you know
okay you made some good predictions
about GPT or whatever what do you think
is going to come next I'm just like this
will just continue
what happened over the last two years is
just going to happen again over the next
two years and it's going to happen again
over the next two years after that and
the next two years after that and then
at some point you're just gonna have a
system that can just do everything it's
going to do it better than anyone else
I know but this is where because the
thing is I'm trying to be measured here
and while I accept that it's it's made
remarkable progress especially in syntax
I can think of all of these you know
limitations and maybe you disagree with
me and we can explore it but you know a
lot of people think that syntax and
meaning is is a wickenstein like
language game for example and you know
it's about finding a shared
understanding and things need to be
grounded in in the real world and
there's the whole implicature and
context thing
um so I I can see lots of examples
you know good reasons why we might hit a
limit quite soon but you you don't think
that we will I'm making the simpler
prediction my simpler prediction is is
just if you don't know anything about
the future predict what has happened so
far will happen again unless you have
information otherwise and I have not
seen good in in like good reasons to
believe that there is something will
dramatically change like unless you take
in like compute limitations like we're
soon going to hit the just like physical
limits of how big we can build computers
and how big of trading loans we can do
that still figures out like gbd4 is
still around the Horizon and I you know
we can do a GPT 4.5 it's going to get
tricky to get to a gpd5 with current
hardware and budgets
um you know if things scale as they have
so far so we're catching up on like
investment
um overhang you know because gbd3 costs
you know like a few million dollars to
make you know big companies can can
spend more than that if they need to
they can spend
you know tens of millions or hundreds of
millions but billions it's going to get
a bit tricky trillions probably not so
okay so No One's Gonna spend a trillion
dollars on a Model I'm gonna I'm
predicting in the next you know five
years the 10 years who knows probably
not but who knows
um but billion maybe like 100 million
yeah absolutely like I expect that like
jvt4 probably costs 100 million or
something that in that order of
magnitude and if not then such models
will probably follow soon so we're going
to see a really big increase in that
regard and there will be some amount of
diminishing returns obviously you know
going from 10 million to 100 million
um
it doesn't give you a 10x battery model
at every task obviously so there is some
amount of diminishing returns in that
regard but there's also a bunch of other
progress that we're also making you know
we're also developing better training
data we're developing better methods of
training better recipes you know better
applications better interfaces better
whatever I I think there are bottlenecks
there
um I I know of some that I think other
people haven't even realized yet but
they don't seem like fundamental to me
they're not like like metaphysical
limitations it's just like oh it's just
engineering like people are just gonna
run into these bottlenecks who knows oh
our model is running out of data or you
know oh it does we don't have big enough
computers or whatever and then you're
just gonna solve that it's just kind of
my prediction I'm just kind of betting
on human Ingenuity if when you can make
money
interesting yeah because I think I would
I would characterize you as a kind of
Universalist in in the sense that I
think you believe that the the algorithm
of intelligence should be as simple as
possible which should have a single
learning objective the intelligence
should emerge from that and one
indication of a bottleneck is when lots
of people say okay well it looks like
there's limitations here so now I'm
going to either adopt a hybrid approach
or I'm going to try and introduce
complexity into the architecture with
new inductive priors I mean I was
speaking to Sarah hooker earlier and she
was talking all about you have these
noisy atypical data sets most of the
representational capacity is wasted
because you know like on the common
cruel Corpus like most of most of it's
crap basically and she cites fairness
problems so you know they're starting to
introduce massive amounts of complexity
in in terms of like how we structure and
Sample and filter the data and I know
that you folks did that with the life AI
models so um is it do you think that's
that's like a step away from this idea
of like let's just blank select
Universal simple learning algorithm not
particularly and I don't know if I would
describe myself as any kind of purist in
any kind of Dimension I'm the way I
think about intelligence is intelligence
is a you know kind of a
practical observational light descriptor
that we put on a wide variety of systems
there's many many ways you can design
these systems there's many many ways
these systems could be built they can be
all kinds of different kinds of Jank you
know I think it's probably possible you
can hard code a AI theoretically if you
had a million years you know just write
it all down in prologue you know I mean
probably
um you know the lookup table probably
doesn't work that take exponential time
but
um
it seems pretty odd what I do believe is
that there are algorithms that are quite
simple that if given sufficient compute
and data can produce extremely
intelligent systems and I think these
um these algorithm we I think we're far
from having discovered like the most
optimal or the most efficient algorithms
I think like neural networks back prop
Transformers are like progress compared
to like earlier algorithms we had but I
don't expect this to be the limit
whatsoever I expect it to be like you
know aliens from outer space came and
showed us their like textbook on AI it
would contain algorithms we've never
heard of you know yeah and we'll get to
that in a little while when we speak
about like the rationalist conception of
intelligence but it's the least
anthropocentric one and it's one that
doesn't really resemble intelligence in
the way that we ensure it or we think
about things which is very interesting
yeah I consider human brains to be in
intelligence it is a way you can build
an intelligence system to a certain
degree it has certain properties of
certain you know ups and downsides like
I I remember I was talking to uh this is
a bit of a schizo Theory but like I was
talking to someone about like I know I
want to know what the topic was we're
talking about psychology I think and
we're talking about like trauma and then
one per and whenever there's a trauma
discussion on the internet one person
thinks everything is trauma and someone
else will come in and say oh trauma's
just a made-up concept and so where my
where I come on and that is that I think
actually trauma is a real concept but
only in humans it's just as an
implementation detail of how the brain
processes fear like with the amygdala
which just happens to be true but you
don't you could build an intelligence
that just does not have this property
most other intelligences there's some
properties that most intelligence will
share such as preferring some things
over other things if you don't have that
well it doesn't really do anything does
it so and like yeah and like so an alien
probably has something that looks like
fear or like dislike but it doesn't have
to have the concept of trauma it doesn't
have to concept it doesn't have most of
our emotions it doesn't have to have the
concept of love it doesn't have to have
the concept of anger it could good they
just have to some so some of these
things are like probably pretty
Universal like dislike is probably
pretty Universal but like all the like
lots and lots of things that others are
human
you know you can build systems that are
like that and there's reasons that
Evolution built those this way and gave
us these various properties but they're
not Universal and there are systems that
do not have these yeah yeah I mean I
just did a show with um Chalmers and we
spoke about um Lego's bat and that's
this thought experiment that you know we
can't really understand what it is like
to be a bet
Thomas talks about this subject of
experience that you're speaking about
almost as being something on the side
which is orthogonal actually orthogonal
in a different way you know like in
intelligent systems in in his view they
have behavior and Dynamics and function
and then you have all of this subjective
stuff on the side and it's not entirely
clear what we do with that and maybe
that's also one of the features of the
rationalist conception in the sense that
we we almost just explicitly don't don't
care about it we just kind of like say
that that's on the side yeah so
fundamentally I mean you know we could
we could waste a lot of time talking
about epiphenomenalism and quality and
whatever I think these things are like
amusing to get high with your friends
and like pretend you're making
intellectual progress but it's just not
really what I fundamentally care about
I'm like practical in the sense where
like sure it's it's it's fun to argue
about what qualia does a bat have sure
that's or you know Whispering the word
Consciousness and you know or like uh
Universal love or whatever but and
I what I fundamentally care about
intelligence I want to think it's
practical or questions about how does it
work how does it accomplish goals how
you know how to how motivational systems
work when we build such systems how can
we get to do things that we want and not
do things we don't want
um I'm also very interested in like so I
am interested in Practical questions
related to this list for example like
what is pain or like what is suffering
and is it like a physical process that
can be like if I give you a blob of
matter and I ask you the question does
this blob of matter currently suffer is
this an objective question or not this
is not obvious to me and I don't think
any philosophy I've read has made good
progress on this question like some
people will say things like whatever you
know human brain being tortured
obviously suffering but then I'm like
okay but like where in the atoms does
that exactly happen and this is I think
is really relevant and will be even more
relevant as you know we get better at
like like if we simulate a human in a
computer and we torture the simulation
is that morally bad or can you do that
because it doesn't because it lacks the
the magic you know quality Edge use I
usually default to just like well it's
just like not do that just just to be
careful like just be safe how would you
like not do that
and I'm skeptical of like philosophical
views that say that that's fine without
like a lot of further justification but
ultimately I'm pragmatic like
intelligence is a property about the
physical world not some hypothetical
thing it's not some religious concept it
is a real thing that exists in the real
world and the question of how it works
and how it can be built and how it can
be controlled and implemented and so on
are questions of Science and Engineering
not metaphysics okay I mean I I see
where you're coming from and let's both
agree that the qualia the subjective
component that's something that you know
it's anthropomorphic but could you also
argue that goals and functioning
capability and behavior are kind of
anthropomorphic so like if you build an
AI system
um it still has an objective function um
you know we might discretize time in a
certain way
um is this also us projecting our own
kind of way of understanding the world
into the model as well yeah I agree I
think it's I think it's anthropomorphic
in the same way quantum physics is
anthropomorphic or uh Newtonian physics
maybe a better example but quantum
physics works too where there is no such
thing as like gravity or forces like
reality doesn't work that way reality is
much weirder than that and we can Pro or
like objects objects don't exist really
like they're just an abstraction that
humans use to simplify how and compress
regularities we see in reality I think
of utility functions or like um agents
or whatever as similarly as useful
abstractions not truths about reality
reality is fundamentally some kind of
weird bizarre
dynamical system which has
substructures which can be usefully
compressed or you know approximated by
talking about agents or you know
optimizes with desires but fundamentally
yes you're absolutely correct there is
no there is no um you know ontologically
primitive agent if you zoom down far
enough on a human eventually you just
see proteins and just atoms there's no
magic you know thinking use it's all
just emergent phenomena it's all just
higher level abstractions over very
simple you know systems
okay well um because because you say we
could just build AI with prologue but it
would be too you know high level and
complex so we say okay well let's have
an emergentist framework Which is higher
resolution but maybe it's still not high
enough resolution well I don't think the
the reason you feel at doing it in
prologue is the like higher low level or
emergent test or non-emergent test it's
more that it's we just don't know how to
do that like you know it's just like we
just don't have good theories of like
learning or like uh abstractions about
the world about intelligence like I
expect if as I said aliens gave us a
textbook from their home planet it has
like the theory of intelligence in it I
expected like you know maybe there'll be
multiple theories or whatever but I
expect there to be like some that are
like pretty simple and like pretty
mathematically elegant where
implementing them would be not take many
lines of code or like not many lines of
prologue necessarily but we just don't
know how to do that because we don't
have such theories our like learning
theory in like representation Theory and
such is like very very primitive
compared to like what I expect like you
know future aliens to be to have doesn't
mean we can't develop this Theory I'm
just saying it's just currently not the
case I don't think this is a
fundamentally like unsolvable problem
and so you can kind of like
so I I just expect that you know like
prologue is like a not easy to do if you
lack Theory but there's other ways of
building intelligences that are much
easier to do if you lack Theory such as
you know neural networks and just
training on data is much much much
easier as we can see empirically even if
you don't actually have good theories of
learning like you don't have to learn VC
Theory you know or like you know how to
learn like representational Theory to
get your GPT to train just throw data at
it all you know sure you know we had to
like figure out back prop we had to
figure out whatever but
there's no like real theory of deep
learning and like all the like current
like work and theory of deep learning
which I think is very interesting is
still extremely far from what I would
consider like a actual like theory of
learning like I want a theory where I
can like I Define a network architecture
whatever and a data set and I can learn
what I could predict ahead of time what
abstractions will this model learn
internally what algorithms what circuits
will be implemented internally what will
it not learn will it learn and this is
without running having to run the
network and we are nowhere close to this
level of theoretical understanding
yeah let's explore that a little bit
because you said something interesting a
while ago which is that the when you
look at perplexity
I mean these models are trying to do a
trivial objective right well you know
there might be a birch type objective or
a kind of you know a decoder type
objective and you could look at you
could look at perplexity or you could
look at some of the emergent
capabilities and now we're seeing a bit
of a shift away from post-hoc analysis
and actually trying to white box the
system as you're talking about and
having some kind of dynamic training
Loop which is actually looking at things
other than headline metrics I think
you've been doing some interesting kind
of thinking in the space as well I mean
maybe you can sketch that out
I've been thinking a lot about stuff
like this
um there but just to like make a
difference between what I mean when I
say white box versus this kind of stuff
so when I say white box when I talk
about like learning theory and such
um these are things that I would like
wish for but I don't expect to like
happen anytime soon these would be
systems where
we understand neural networks so
completely they become like you know
decompile them into human readable code
edit one specific fact or like one
specific algorithm or like prove
ethereum on them we could like prove
this neural network or never say a bad
word to a user and we can like prove
this this is super far from where we are
at there theoretically and it's also
different from what you're describing
which is like you know using um you know
different Loops or different of our
metrics and such to like you know move
training around I would still consider
these to be mostly Black Box methods
like anything that involves
back prop is basically black box from my
perspective unless you really know what
you're doing unless then I don't think
we currently really know what we're
doing so
we definitely have seen some especially
the data engineering Dimension we've
seen a lot of people experimenting a lot
more with like making specific training
data sets that have certain Properties
or that like have users interact with a
model and then when I get certain type
of bad attraction happens they will like
fine tune it to like prevent that from
happening whether you stuff like rohf or
other methods like this I think these
are all like variously interesting but I
consider them to be as black box as any
other for the most part like when you
train a model using like say rohf it
like
um on the surface level it might look
more human it's like you're telling the
human the model to do something human
likes human votes up what you tell them
all to do that more you even votes down
to monitor that list it feels in some
sense we have more control but do you
actually know what the model is learning
do you actually know what's in those
gradients du actually I'm telling you
you don't if you did you're some alien
from another planet because currently no
one does so we didn't experiment uh with
this conjecture and there's there's some
technical details I'm going to leave out
from this experience I'm like gotchas
but the overall the headline of
experiment is we looked at
normal GPT models compared to instruct
models we thought these were all our
Jeff models but openai claims they were
not these are great telescope by the way
and what's the name of that article uh
mysteries of mode collapse yeah I um I
told Sarah about that earlier and she
was very interested it's a very
interesting result and so so yeah there
there's a little caveat that we thought
these were all HF models but turns out
they were not at least according to open
AI so are they for all intents and
purposes I mean just the method wasn't
used they were instruct fine-tuned which
is a slightly different method so and
could you I mean just for the audience
could you introduce what we mean by this
kind of fine-tuning to align with human
preference sure so
um instruct and struct fine tuning is a
very simple method where you basically
just write you do create data sets of
examples where you have input and a user
output like the user likes or like and
so on and you just fine-tune it to
follow instructions so these are like
very carefully find and crafted data
sets and you just fine tune those just
like you finding kind of anything else
there's some details there but like yeah
it doesn't matter rohf is a bit more
fancy this is a method where instead of
just training on you know samples you
you have the model generate its own
examples like you or well you give it
you give it a task and you have it then
generate like say two different outputs
and you have humans and you have at
first you have humans rank these and
then you know they say like this one's
been this one and this one's better than
this one it's a little better than this
one
and then you are as an extra step you
can also train the model to predict what
humans like it predicts will humans like
this or not and then you train your
model to optimize the chance that a
human will like its outputs using RL
rather than fine tuning so some tactical
details there don't really matter
um the overall idea is is that you're
trying to take these pre-trained models
which are kind of just like these big
blobs of like useful things and trying
to like tweak them towards more likely
or closer to what humans want them to do
first glance seems like a great idea you
know sounds sounds great to me you know
you tell the model to do things humans
like thumbs up thumbs down great yeah
cool and
so this is pretty tricky to do in
practice but open AI seems to have got
some really great results results out of
it
um with enough labeling and a
fine-tuning enough uh you can tweaking
the hyper parameters you can make really
useful models we don't know exactly like
like what chat EBT is but I I think but
we do know that like the text DaVinci 3
I think is an RL HF model and I've heard
from people that's quite good
um so you know it's their own so
to go back to the mysteries of mode
collabs we saw this interesting
phenomena which by the way does not
really happen with the newer model so I
think open AI fixed this problem but
we're not sure it's very confusing and
opening eye does not share information
that freely
um unfortunately we saw this interesting
phenomena of mode collapse
um which I think is actually not the
necessarily the most interesting thing
we observed or well it's a subset of the
most interesting thing so it's a nice
pose you can go read if you want but I
think the headline result that I'd like
to talk about is there's this phenomena
where if you ask a raw GPT model for a
random number you check the like
probability of the various digits it was
actually pretty random which is already
kind of weird but you know it wasn't
perfect you know it was like you know I
preferred like 42 a little more than
other ones but like overall I was like
it was a pretty even distribution but
then as you look to instruct tuned
models
like I think like 70 of the mass or what
was like concentrated on like two or
three numbers yeah it had like favorite
numbers
and so
why this is interesting to me is
um shortly opening I didn't train them
to have a favorite number that was of
course that wasn't an intentional thing
it wasn't that that was like something
we're attempting to do what's
interesting so my theory whatever what I
expect happened here was is that they
were trained for some totally different
things they were trained for instruct
training they were trained for you know
rohf or whatever right and then in that
process there just happened to be some
kind of correlation to some numbers or
like some gradients just happen to push
things in some certain direction and
that caused this model to suddenly
change its distribution rather wildly
over things that were never in the
intended target and so this is what
happens this is what I expect will
happen continue to happen when you train
huge black boxes of models by just you
know throwing these like massive amounts
of gradients at them
with like you know some samples you came
up with sure it like probably will be
like more polite on average these are
polite samples but suddenly maybe it
will start really really liking I know
strawberries more than blueberries if
you ask it and like maybe that's amusing
and maybe that's harmless but it shows
how little we really understand these
things it shows that we really don't
know what we're doing when we do these
things and it's very much empirical and
that's like fine if it's just you know
some text models or something or
something you know it I mean it can
still cause problems there but I'm
particularly concerned about this as
these systems become more powerful and
more integrated into society as these
systems become more capable of you know
performing independent actions and
interacting with the environment
um you know writing code manipulating
humans etc etc
anthropic actually recently released the
paper which I have not yet read but it
looks really good I I was skinned it if
I haven't read any detail where they
look into how especially early Jeff
models as they become larger and more
trained become very psychophanic in the
sense that they will say false things
that humans like hearing and they get
and it's very consistent it doesn't like
as malls get larger they not become more
truthful to not become more accurate
they become better at telling humans
what they want here which really is no
surprise like uh everyone I feel like
should have predicted that ahead of time
like if you train them to do the things
humans like they will do that whether or
not it's good because it's handsome of
good or truthful or such is much more
complicated than will humans give me
thumbs up or thumbs down
so I'd like to explore this kind of
paradox that in in many ways we've
nerfed the models by doing the rlhf and
surely we haven't right surely on many
of the headline benchmarks the models
are better with our lhf I agree with you
that we have made them more
anthropomorphic and I was fascinated in
your mode collapse article because
you're basically saying that before it
was there was this Rich creativity to
the model and when you look at the um
you know like the probability
distribution of the next token it was it
was almost like you know like a packet
of maltesers I mean you never know what
you're going to get and that actually
kind of if you knew what you were doing
that that opened up lots of
possibilities we were just speaking
before about how I think folks in your
community don't think that AI should be
anthropocentric so we've made it more
anthropocentric have we nerfed it have
we brutalized it or made it more robust
it's not clear to me what the answer is
it depends on what you mean by
brittleness or robust it in the sense
that is it less likely to say something
the user doesn't like it's become more
robust in that regard you look at your
apt right you know ask it something
terrible and it's more robust and then
you know like Da Vinci was if you ask Da
Vinci to say something terrible it's
quite quite happy to do so and it
doesn't really care while so
the interesting question there's no
Universal sense in what is right or
wrong there is no Universal correct goal
function or incorrect goals there's it's
all what was the user intending so in
many ways rlhf can you know to some
degree improve you know that like open
AI wants their model to be political
correct it's a goal they wanted to have
and maybe as a result of this it will
become less creative and like less good
at like writing great schizophrenic you
know massive volumes of fiction or
whatever maybe that's a trade-off they
want to make
is it probably is it possible to do both
probably do we know how I mean as I say
we don't really have any theories we're
just kind of like is a purely empirical
science like currently machine learning
is more like biology than it is like you
know like computer science it's so much
of it is just kind of like poking a
thing putting some chemicals in stirring
it around seeing what happens and we can
like push things in certain directions
and such but it's not like it's not as
if someone could say oh okay I I want my
model to now have this property like I
want uh chat GPT but I wanted to also be
really creative at writing this type of
stories and then I just like you know
rewrite it to do that
we don't know how to do that you can
like train on some data and like hope it
figures it out and I sometimes that
works but
it's very much empirical in this regard
and so the idea of like nerfing or not
really depends on what your goals are if
your goals is to have a cool
schizophrenic writing Aid then yeah the
rhf models are probably a bit worse uh
in various ways if your goal is to have
a you know useful helper bot that
doesn't say any naughty words then rhf
is at least somewhat helpful it is not a
solution to the problem as you know
Twitter found within you know like 60
Minutes of chat GPT going live you can
very amusingly you know just like
find prompts that will make the model
totally ignore its its tuning there and
say bad things or like things it's not
supposed to talk about and such which is
very amusing and but again it just shows
um Scott Alexander is a great post about
this
um on the blog Asheville codex 10 where
he points out which I very strongly
agree with this idea that hey maybe it's
bad that the best AI lab in the entire
world that tried as hard as they could
can't control their AI like whether you
agree or disagree that like you know
having this kind of like or Pro you know
like you know mealy mouth AI is like
good or bad
is it kind of disturbing that the best
possible lab who put massive amounts of
effort still failed like the model still
will happily you know tell you how to
cook meth as long as you just like ask
it to do it in like ooVoo speak or
whatever right it's like as long as
you're like slightly trick yet you like
put it a little bit weird you can still
get these models to do all these kind of
things that Oprah and I worked you know
it was like one of the best labs in the
world the best scientists in the world
putting millions of dollars into
contractors for labeling and you know
changing things and controlling things
and they still can't get the models to
do what they want yeah that seems like a
problem
let's talk a little bit about
gatekeeping now there are concentric
circles so the the folks in the ethics
Community they say we should control
these models from the point of view of
misinformation for example or you know
they might reinforce um biases in
society Etc et cetera and in a way I was
I didn't like that argument against
Galactica I I thought Galactica was a
wonderful tool I've done a PhD I'm
perfectly capable of verifying
information myself I don't trust
everything a language model tells me so
I was I was kind of annoyed at that form
of gatekeeping and I wonder whether you
would be too but but in a way you're a
fan of a much bigger form of gatekeeping
which is that these models could
potentially form an existential threat
and therefore we should restrict their
use or not necessarily now but a future
iteration of them much worse than that
favorite sentence is much worse than
that so like the whole misinformation
thing is I've talked to many of these
misinformation people and they're honest
people I want to like make this clear
even if I disagree with some of these
people and like I'm also maybe
politically or so whatever for the most
part they're very Earnest people that
are trying to prevent harm and are
trying to do what's right even if you
disagree with them and I you know wish
that sides could just like see the most
of the time each other are trying to
actually just do the right thing from
their perspective and
so
so and my reaction when I was talking to
a lot of these misinformation people is
I was just like
it's so much worse than all you guys
think like what are you talking about
they're like oh it could generate like
some like uh spam emails I'm like man
that would be like harmless you can do
much worse things with these models like
like be a bit creative like what do you
think that like a sophisticated like you
know psyop operation where you can just
like clone virtual humans that can
become friends and infiltrate
communities actively like what do you
think that can do like oh my God like
the world isn't ready I've been I've
written essays about this like three or
four years ago I wrote a big bunch of
essays where I was when I was first
working with GPT where I just saw the
writing on the wall I'm like oh the
internet's gonna end like like you will
not be able to under to to understand
you could talk to someone for years of
your life you can become friends with
them they can like hold your hand
through the worst parts of your life and
they were about the whole time that's
the Brave New World we're approaching
that's the if we don't integrate like
some kind of like you know widely
distributed proof of humanity then
that's just what the it's going to be
like you know catfishing on levels you
know hitherto unknown to man and I've
been like so it's very funny I kind of
like pissed off both sides I piss off
both the like Hall Monitor type people
because I don't care enough about their
like political correctness things like
what because I'm like and I freak out
but and I also not the Libertarians also
don't like me because I'm always like oh
yeah oh this is gonna like you know be
much worse like scammers are gonna mind
control everybody and well not literally
but like and then I also piss off all of
these people combined because I still
don't think any of these problems are in
the top five worst problems that AI are
gonna cause
well I mean let's explore this a little
bit because it's similar to the argument
of paternalism on Instagram so you know
you let teenage girls on there and they
might be groomed and so on but in a
weird way it has the opposite effect
because it kind of it it's almost like
it trains teenage girls to
um be you know to defend themselves and
and to kind of recognize harmful
situations and to put the Batman out I
can tell you you don't agree with that
but it's a it's a weird form of
paternalism and and social
conservativism which is actually weird
from Progressive folks on on the left
because they're saying that even now
with DaVinci 3 if you have a response on
LinkedIn or you get an email you don't
know that it's coming from that person
um in all likelihood it may have been
generated by a large language model that
we're in that reality now and you can
draw a line in the sand and you can say
no I don't want because it is going to
train Society it's already changing
Society you can say I don't like this I
want things to stay as they as they were
and the same people are saying oh um you
know our values are changing and the
models need to reflect on new values
because they they see Society
differently so that seems like a
contradiction to me
I don't care what other people think
like shift other people have stupid
political opinions and that's just not
my problem
um and if people don't understand
technology I think
a lot of people so what I do feel like
what has happened is that there's a big
massive ball of problems coming at us
and
this whole problem this whole sphere of
problems is so big that it doesn't fit
into any one ideological Niche cleanly
it's not it doesn't fit into the story
of the left it doesn't fit into the
story of the right isn't fit into the
story of the Libertarians it doesn't fit
at the story in the progressives it
doesn't fit of the story of anyone
really because it's like fundamentally
not human it's like fundamentally just
like not the kind of problems we've
dealt with in the past we have to deal
with things such as like you know human
identity is not making you know that
many sense anymore humans no longer
being the dominant species on the planet
you know uh having you know brain
uploads or like the ability to like you
know um produce any form of media or any
kind of manipulation the ability to
um you know immortality whatever right
like these are all problems that just
fundamentally it's kind of like how like
the ideologies of the Middle Ages had to
give way to the ideology of the
Industrial Age like communism didn't
make sense in the middle age like you
you could explain it to people and it
would make sense because it was dealing
with problems that didn't exist it was
dealing with ontologies that didn't
exist it only started making sense when
you had radio and telephone and steam
engines and labor and capital and such
like there wasn't really Capital the
same way that Marx would describe it in
the middle age there was but like not
really you know and or like democracy
like didn't really make that much sense
if you never moved more than a mile out
of your hometown and like there was no
big Nations or something like sure you
can like always like you know find some
weird version of it but it wasn't a
natural fit for the kinds of problems
that a medieval servant a peasant would
face like ideologies like Marxism or
fascism or democracy are like they don't
make sense it only in the industrial and
then the mid and then the modern area
where these land of ideologies started
like becoming relevant because they were
addressing this Brave New World this new
world with new problems with new
fundamental differences and it's often
the case that you have some like
Progressive reactions to things you have
some like reactionary like you know
you know conservative reactions these
kind of things but like if you took the
most conservative like person in the
west today and you put them back in the
Middle Ages they would be the most
radical Progressive person that medieval
servant peasant has like ever met in
their entire life they would be like
what what do you do like what that's
like they would be they would be
completely comprehensible to them we
would be aliens to them and we're going
through another one of the shifts right
now basically is that these shifts
happen because of Technology you shifts
happen uh because what it means to be
human is redefined by our economic
systems get redefined our like abilities
to interact with each other get
redefined and we go through another one
of the shifts right now is that none of
the stories that we have been telling
ourselves over the last 100 years
work in this new regime like like
democracy and like Fascism and Marxism
are all fundamentally based on humans
like none of these stories are built
around okay what if there's things that
aren't humans that also can do
everything then all like you know does
democracy make sense if do the robots
get to vote do the ads get to vote not
when why not like you can you can
develop versions of democracy that are
the Democratic ideology that address
these problems but it's not inherent to
democracy these new ideologies have not
yet been developed and we're we're you
know we're in this phase of like you
know the old world is dying and the new
world struggles to be born and now is
the time of monsters this is where we're
currently at and people are starting to
realize this they're starting to realize
that that their stories are still quite
work
and everyone's confused and they expect
us to get worse I expect people to get
more and more confused so yeah you know
you have like people on the left saying
like misuse or whatever and you have
people in the right saying whatever the
people on the right say I don't know and
then but none of this really captures
the real problem the real problems are
much weirder than that they're much
worse than that like you know you can
talk about taxes and capitalism and
Marxism as much as you want but if
humans just provide no more labor
because all of it is done by machines
well then you know Marxism doesn't have
an answer to that either and neither
does capitalism none of these systems
have an answer to this so if you really
want to talk about LG and you really
want to talk about how the future is
going to go I don't know how it's going
to go and I don't think anyone currently
does I don't think any of the current
stories are going to survive there has
to be some news story there has to be
some new thing that's gonna have to
happen really goddamn quick because uh
technology is not slowing down and
things are going really fast
does it worry you do you think that
there is a kind of linear interpolation
between where we are now and where we're
going or do you think it's going to be
an extremely bumpy ride I think it's an
extremely bumpy like
there's like no world I can imagine or
like the next five years aren't
extremely crazy like if the next five
years are really normal you can like
throw tomatoes at eat and like call
these and put a little gestures hat on
me but like there's like no way I can
imagine things not being extremely crazy
over the next five years and then the
five ways after that are going to be
even more crazy and the five years after
that are gonna be even more crazy than
that
can you can you sketch out some some
examples I mean I think you're alluding
to one interesting uh phenomenon a
little while ago which is that some of
the some of some of the people that you
interact with in the future might just
be AI agents you know and they are in
some sense indistinguishable from from
real human beings and there'll be a
massive disruption of the workforce and
so on but can you know can you like put
a bit of color into that Vision just so
we know what you're talking about I mean
so I don't like doing too much futurism
and the reason I don't like to do
futurism is people people over anchor on
specific scenarios so I can give
a timeline right and then they'll find
one part of the timeline right like oh
Connor actually that doesn't work
because of this reason you didn't know
therefore I dismiss all of your
arguments so there's really little for
me to gain when I'm like okay here's 10
Things I expect eight or more of them to
probably happen but I don't know which
eight like that's like that's how I
think about things I'm like you know 50
that like eight or more of these I don't
know which ones turn out to be true and
then
but then you know someone will like
nitpick some of them and then they'll
ignore all the ones that do happen so so
I I can do that
I can I can give you such worlds that I
think are like plausible and also
there's the old but this is also the
problem that I think the truly most
plausible worlds are too weird to be in
the Overton window like there's this
concept called Future Shock levels and
the idea is there's like several shock
levels a person can be at it's like how
comfortable they are with like various
extreme levels of like potential sci-fi
features and the saying is usually you
should never try to explain something to
someone who that is above there's more
than one above their future shock level
if you explain something to someone it's
more than one a level above their future
shock level they'll just become confused
or they'll be scared or they'll start
worshiping you or they'll like or
they'll like yell at you they it's like
it becomes impossible to communicate
people can like only handle things are
like one future shot level above them so
usually it's not productive to like talk
about what the far future will look like
because it just frightens people yeah
and so I can give you like some
prediction for next year I think that's
probably not gonna be that weird but if
you ask me how things can look at 5 10
20 50 years
it's gonna be weird yeah because I was I
was reading this book called the
rationalist Guide to the Galaxy and it
was really um I recommend folks actually
read that talking all about the Genesis
of less wrong and Robin Hansen and
elieza and and uh Bostrom and Howard
many of these ideas uh formed and we'll
go into some some of the core beliefs uh
in in a minute but
um I think it was elieza who coined this
Future Shock thing and I think he has
Future Shock level four which is like
the the mind-blowing one that that most
people wouldn't wouldn't understand but
um talking about long-termism in
particular this is one thing that a lot
of people take umbrage with they say
that we're talking about something that
sounds like science fiction so it rests
on this idea of existential risk being
incredibly important and the most
significant thing for Humanity right now
is to survive the next 100 years and the
thought experiment sounds like science
fiction because it's talking about for
example the moral value of future
simulated lives on another planet having
because there's so many of them kind of
like having more
um moral valence than let's say people
starving in Africa now I mean what do
you think about that so if you're hoping
for a really spicy defender of
long-termism you got the wrong guy
because I am far more practical than
that yeah I don't think you need any
funky long-termist bustromian like
simulation arguments to justify extra
speaking problem I'm like if you want
your kids to grow up you want to survive
this entry you know that's like as
practical as it gets uh like you know
look if I could just get to my kids and
your kids and you know all of our kids
to grow up into the next Century I would
be really happy about that and I'm not
even confident we're going to get to
there so sure I I can like you know
I think there's a lot to be said for
long-termism to be clear I think there's
like a lot of like actually pretty
strong philosophical arguments there but
I don't think they're I think they're
also like too clever for their own good
um this is a problem that a lot of
rationalists thinking have is they're
just too clever for their own good
they'll come up with these massive
Galaxy brain arguments which is like at
all this complexity and go through all
these things and then come of these like
weird like mostly like not really usable
Solutions or like ideas or something and
like yeah some of them I understand and
it makes sense some of them I also think
it's fun like it's kind of it's fun to
read bustrum's papers and just kind of
like go along for the ride I enjoy it it
tickles my brain you know and I think
he's probably right about many things
there's some things I think he's wrong
about
but
what do you think he's wrong about oh
that's a long that's a long talk that's
a long discretion but about like the
moral value of like um
person moments
um and like how to like uh integrate
those over infinite universes so that's
a that's a topic We're not gonna talk
about now interesting yeah I mean
because one of the Hallmarks of Boston
is he has these thought experiments
where he makes sort of like and it's
always logically impeccable you know
like one one Leap then one Leap then one
Leap each one rests on the one before
even with the simulation argument it's
something I mean we've spoken about this
before but you know I also totally don't
buy that one I think it's already
exactly bad I actually think that's his
worst argument oh interesting because my
my conception was Maybe I'm Wrong that
much of rationalism
um maybe not but certainly long term
isn't rests on the simulation argument
because it kind of starts where the
universe is made of information
um you know we might already be in a
simulation or if not now in the future
most of the living beings will be
simulated human beings so so why I don't
know Hamas would differ from other
rationals in this regard but like
whenever I I have this like class like
I'm not a utility at classical guitar by
any sense and I think anyone who who is
a classic utilitarian is insane because
humans can't be utilitarians it doesn't
work it's too hard it's too
computationally hard like this is like
what Eleazar talks about in his essay
um dying with Dignity where he talks
about this like phenomena where you talk
to rationalists and then they're all
like well okay you know hey I ask
destroy the world they'll cause infinite
suffering blah blah blah so you must do
anything possible so let's uh uh let's
go blow up tsmc yeah and then and I'm
just
that's so dumb like that is so
unimaginably stupid
and you would actually consider that a
like reasonable plan and so
my diagnosis which I think is the same
as eliezers but I'm not actually sure I
haven't actually talked to him about
this so I'm not sure if he agrees with
my like interpretation of his diagnosis
of the problem like is that what happens
is is that utilitarianism is is good in
theory it is the moral theory that God
should use if you were a god alien from
outer space that has brain the size of
Jupiter you should be a utilitarian
because that's obviously the correct way
to do things
but you're not
and none of us are and if you try to
approximate this God algorithm of you
know morality or whatever then what
happens is is that in practice you just
Galaxy bring yourself into rationalizing
whatever stupid you were gonna do
anyways but now you feel really smug
about it you know well I mean because
utilitarianism is a strand of
consequentialism are you a
consequentialist okay you correct the
consequentialism is the the way God
should do morality
so you're not you are or you're not a
consequentialist practically no that so
that's a huge surprise for me
um I I kind of see consequentialism as
being the core framework underpinning
the rationalist yeah so I mean I would
describe myself I guess as an aspiring
consequentialist
so I wish I was a consequential but I'm
not stupid in the sense that if I
thought I was a consequentialist if I
thought that I could actually evaluate
the consequence of my actions and I act
accordingly that would be stupid because
I can't obviously not so for example
if I if an alien from outer space came
out of the UFO handed me a gun and said
here you have to shoot your mother
otherwise I'll blow up the planet the
rational thing is not to be well okay
I'm gonna go kill my mom it'll be like
obviously I'm insane right now like you
should just be like okay obviously I'm
crazy this is not actually happening I
am insane you know and so
there's like the untold so like
deontology in the sense of having rules
over like things you just like don't do
by default even if they look good is
is in a sense
much more shame for a human because
there are just some things some
scenarios that are so weird you can
evaluate them so just defaults to your
rules your rules it so I have a strong
identology in the sense that like you
know an alien asked me to come my mom
not gonna do that it's not gonna happen
and you know if and you can justify this
or consequential as grounds you can you
can Galaxy brain yourself into being
like well well actually it's it's
optimal for you to not to be
consequentialist it's consequently
Optical if you're not be content I'm
like yeah yeah sure fine okay cool but
like just like
like just come on nerd yeah I mean
that's a real surprise to me I was
listening to a Sam Harris podcast
recently he was talking about the FTX
thing and effective altruism and
obviously he's a consequentialist but he
was kind of arguing that we are all
consequentialist to a degree you know
there are kind of grades of of
consequentialism yeah maybe yeah I think
grades consequential absence is a better
way to describe it in the sense that
like sure ultimately I care about good
outcomes but I don't think me doing the
like you consequentialist algorithms is
actually the right way for me to do that
as a human and like reflective in the
sense that like
it's like my my real morality doesn't
actually have a word I think in
philosophy at least I'm aware of it it's
a longer topic but like I'm self-aware
in the sense that I'm like
there are scenarios over which I may not
reason so to speak and so this my
argument against the simulation argument
that bellstra makes so Bostrom Buster
makes his argument where like he makes
like three proposals and like well if
this is true and this is true in this
and through then we must believe that
we're likely in a simulation and like no
absolutely not because for me there's an
illegal step he makes and a legal step
and the legal step he makes is is
reasoning about all universes and like
no you can't reason overall universes
that's insane you can't do that you
can't do a a computational operation
over a set of that large and if you try
to do a computation over a set that
large whatever it outputs is just some
your priors made up and if you then
take that to believe that it has like
some metaphysical value you're just
confused you can do that for fun you
know you can just like you know if you
if you're aware of what you're doing you
know you're just making some up and
I mean fine but what I disagree with a
very strongly this is a longer topic
about like um
a causality in large universes and so on
is that
we're computationally bounded creatures
we are we cannot reason or sufficiently
large objects and if we may do
computational these large objects
whatever comes out of them is determined
not by the large object but by our
approximation it's determined by our
priors it's PRI it's a rationalization
technique so it just doesn't give it
some kind of like ontologically
privileged status which I think some
rationalists believe they believe that
like a simulation argument gets extra
credit because it's like making an
argument about the larger world but for
me it's like no that that it is an
invalid reasoning I don't know if any of
this make any sense well it is but it
kind of feels like we are flitting
between describing humans and Connor and
describing the universe and and it and
its makeup well it's just important
instead to like Carter knows that he
can't answer this question so he refuses
to instead of just making some up I
refuse to make up an answer I'm just
like I don't know and it's a similar
thing with like with the
consequentialist thing is that like
consequentialism it's like the
difference between like consequentials
and deontology is kind of like the
difference between p and NP is like the
ontology can always be you know like
this is not true just like you know take
us a metaphor is metaphorically can
always be evaluated in P time because
like you don't have some rules you check
if the rules applying you either do you
don't consequentialism is fundamentally
NP hard is that you have to actually
reason about the universe you have to
reason about the consequences you have
to reason about all possible universes
in which you could exist and how your
effects could affect these various
universes so it fundamentally becomes an
NP hard problem and so
if you know that you are not an empty
Oracle you can't do NP complete
computations and you are presented with
an NP hard problem that gives you some
weird up answer my suggestion is
don't do it but the reason I find this
interesting is it's it's not just the
rationalism folks in the ethics
Community as well they say that
Engineers are crappy at doing ethics and
the underlying kind of theme Here is
that our software is bugging I mean
you've just basically given an example
of it and that's why we need to turn off
our emotive gut reactions and we need to
do things that are unintuitive to us and
my understanding of all of rationalism
is based on this simple idea that even
though you think your intuition is is to
be deontological you should just put
that to one side and say no we need to
just think about this rationally we need
to think about the consequences yeah and
I mean this is all fine and dandy in
theory but in practice this you know
ends up with people
getting into very bad situations very
often
um because no actually so sure
some of your instincts are really bad
and you should not listen to them you
know your instincts tell you to you know
hurt people or something because you're
angry don't do that it's bad don't do
that
um but you have a lot of instincts that
are actually really good so this is uh
you know it's it's a phenomena that can
happen where people have like
they feel bad about something they don't
have a reason to feel bad about it just
don't like it and then sometimes people
can be like well you're being irrational
you should just like it anyways and my
answer is just off you know if you
feel uncomfortable and you don't like
something then you can just not to do it
and that's okay and you don't have to
justify yourself but
it's not either or it's both of these
are terrible you lose in both scenarios
is it like your instincts are wrong in
all kinds of different scenarios for
example yes you should actually donate
to the most effective Charities and if
you don't do that I think you're like
pretty obviously up
um I'm giving stated preference to most
people that they want to save lives et
cetera et cetera like that's like that's
an obvious thing like when I donate
money I donate to one not to ones that I
made me like feel nice and fuzzy or
whatever I donate to ones that just you
know save the most lives per dollar
that's just what I do but it's not in
but
the mistake that rationalists I think
make
sometimes this is not to be clear
not all of them yeah no a monolithic yes
non-monolithic group at all and that
sometimes happens is that people think
that it gives this dead like this type
of evidence this type of thinking is
like infallible or has like privileged
ontological status and has
some amount of primitive of privilege in
its ontological status
not infinitely so it's still an
algorithm running on human software and
if you and you can absolutely justify
anything to yourself with
consequentialism if you're clever enough
and many people who are consequentials
are very clever so they can justify
anything to themselves
yeah and I mean I think we've seen that
recently there was actually um a Twitter
post I saw which is that ironically FTX
didn't um consider the consequence of
the The Exchange going down in in the
way it did I mean that guy in one of the
one of the interviews he said he said
he'll just like he'll just bite the
bullet on Saint Petersburg Paradox which
is just
the most Galaxy brain I've
ever heard in my life exactly but I mean
but to sum up this little segment a
little bit it sounds like you're saying
if you were in god mode and you actually
because what we're talking about is
taking trajectories for an exponential
space and humans are fallible and can't
do that so if we if we were in god mode
then then we would be consequentialists
yeah and also if I think you would agree
that the conception of AI from
rationalness is a consequential one
because it's all about this
um you know basically having a utility
function having
um you know maximizing the let's say the
reward the discounted reward over that
trajectory so it would be a
consequentialist agent so
there's a lot of subtlety in that issue
that usually doesn't get brought up so
you're correct that this is the this is
the tldr version but there's a lot of
solely actually in the so this is the
version you'd hear from I think also
from like many rationalists but this is
not the version you would hear if you
like sat down with Eleazar for like a
long time yeah it would give you a much
more complex nuanced version or he
wouldn't because he wouldn't you know he
wouldn't care to but hypothetically if
you took the time he'll give you a way
more nuanced version of this
so there's like um there's a great post
by Eleazar I'm trying to remember what
it was called it was something like um
consistent preferences implies
consistent utilities something like that
I remember it's like
it's the idea that hearing's theorems
are actually
way simpler and more natural than people
think they are so a lot of the like
ideas of like the merely rationals type
thinking of intelligence comes from
coherence theorems and from like Dutch
booking so Dutch booking is the idea is
that if an agent is incoherent in
certain ways you can extract infinite
resources from it so if an agent for
example prefers you know uh B to a and
it prefers C to B and it prefers a to c
and you then you can offer it to trade A
to B to C to A to B to C to a et cetera
infinitely and you get infinite money
out of it yeah so I think we spoke about
this on the first one yeah so I think
you and you would agree that a super
intelligence would probably not be like
that it'd probably not have that or at
least it wouldn't have a computationally
approximatable version of this so This
brings us into stuff like logical
inductors where I do actually expect
that for example humans definitely are
like this like you can definitely do
this to humans but it's so tricky in
practice like that you just it doesn't
work in practice but like a super
intelligence could trick you like this
they could do some super Galaxy brain
super complicated scheme that goes
through 17 000 intermediate States or
whatever that humans just lose track of
and then we could get tricked so I don't
think that humans are like immune to
judge book but we're like robust enough
against Dutch booking they're like
mostly other people can't touch book us
and that's like fine because we don't
deal with super intelligence as we deal
with other humans most other humans
can't touch book us but like for example
mental handicapped people sometimes can
be Dutch booked in this way like even
these very simple ways like mentally
handicapped people often do have these
problems read a terrible Twitter thread
the other day about how mentally
handicapped people are targeted by like
scams and like automated like like Robo
scams and stuff and it's just really
heartbreaking it's really really
terrible
um and so
the conception of like these systems is
like consequentialist or like whatever
is basically found in these coherence
theorems is if you're in if you're in an
environment a competitive environment
where you have to be as smart as
possible if there are certain properties
you just have to have because otherwise
a smarter thing just destroys you
because it's just smarter than you and
the idea and so consequentialism is kind
of like a side effect of that where you
have to have coherent utilities but you
have to have
some things you like in coherent ways if
your utilities are random the smarter
thing can just put Dutch book you if
your preferences are adherent or they're
inconsistent you can be Dutch booked if
you can be Etc now if you are these only
smart thing on the planet
you can do whatever the hell you want
like you will not be as efficient as you
could be you would be more efficient if
you made yourself coherent but you can
meet if you want if you're powerful
enough you can buy incoherence so
incoherence always will give up power it
will always make you less effective at
what you're trying to do you'll waste
resources you wouldn't have otherwise
wasted you'll be exploitable by other
intelligent agents Etc but if you're
smart or powerful enough then yeah it
doesn't matter you know or if you're not
D there's no hyper Predators out there
that you know will Dutch book you
because you know you're the only thing
in the universe then yeah sure fine it
doesn't matter so I think the argument
that like all all things being equal
we should expect
very powerful and very intelligent
systems to be coherent to the better
probability you know to use like
something something base you know I
think those are all like
pretty fair assumptions to make I don't
expect it will literally be exactly like
this and like even the biggest super
intelligence still can't solve NP hard
problems so I still can't do full
consequentialism of course not yeah and
interesting I spoke I spoke to some
folks in Europe it's about you know how
they felt about the rationalist
community and you know just just to be
frank some people think there is a kind
of cultic aspect to it I mean there is
and well that there is I mean you said
it yourself but one of the things that
comes out even in this conversation is
the I mean first of all the average IQ
is very high in this community the
amount of technical jargon renders it
extremely inaccessible I mean just now
we've been talking about Dutch booking
and you know like lots of Bayesian
references and when we're talking about
all the bostroom stuff it's instrumental
convergence and the orthogonality of the
earth thesis and it's all very very
intellectual and every single new piece
of jargon depends on the one that came
before so it feels like
to even kind of understand what the
you're talking about there's like 14
intellectual leaps that you need to make
and from an outside perspective it makes
the community feel very cliquey and I
think that's one of the reasons why
there's a little bit of you know
friction should we say of course I mean
like
rationalism is like the most autistic
Community possible like I think people
just like don't realize this like what
do you think Giga autist you know high
IQ nerds are like if you put them
together in a room this is just what
they're like and I have a lot of
problems with these things as well like
I don't consider myself a rationalist
and
wow for the reason we've been speaking
about many of the reasons people also
just I just fit in I'm just not that
autistic like I genuinely am just not
that autistic and like I went to like
rapture's workshops and it was like the
worst experience of my life everyone was
like super nice you know no one did
anything wrong everyone was like super
open and trying to help I was just like
oh my God I want to kill myself
it's just uh why is no one normal like
can I talk to anyone and they're all
like no one did anything wrong it's just
I think a lot of people don't actually
have a lot of experience dealing with
like actually autistic people like like
very autistic people and so they see
they only meet them online basically I
think a lot of people don't have much
experience dealing with autistic people
in real life or when they do they don't
model them as like neurotypical they
model them as like oh this guy's just an
or he's just so he's just kind
of weirdo or whatever they only have a
good mechanistic model of like how
neurotypical people are different from
moral people and like once I had this
model I was just like oh okay you know
this is just a different culture it's
just things a lot of nice things about
it it's very blunt it's very honest it's
very intellectual people are very
genuine in very you know endearing ways
there's a lot of things that really
really truly truly love about the
rationalist movement and the people
involved in it but there's also lots of
problems also lots of things about them
that really annoy the hell out of me
they're you know and they can be like
very abrasive and it can be
it's very funny when I talk to people
about like uh alignment and like stuff
like that the number one thing that
determines whether this is going to be a
good conversation or not is whether they
have heard of rationalists or not
because if they have it's going to be
bad like oh no how do I explain this so
I actually don't really like talking
about rationalism very much I don't like
talking about that's wrong very much
even so I like these people and I work
with a lot of these people but the
problems of existential risk alignment
AI are completely independent of this
like it's just this is just the
community that happens to discover this
problem first this is the community that
happens to have focused the most on this
problem I think on a coincidence that
you know the blonde autistic high IQ
Community would hyper focus on very
important problems I I think you know if
AI risk wouldn't be a problem they
wouldn't have discussed they would have
discovered like you know nuclear power
or like climate change or whatever you
know very early on like you know the
rational settings like so funny story
rationalists actually did exist
technically before around world over one
so there is a Polish Doberman named
Alfred grozowski who after seeing the
horrors of World War One thought that as
technology keeps improving well wisdom's
not improving then the world will end
and All Humans will be eradicated so we
must focus on producing human
rationality in order to prevent this
existential catastrophe this is a real
person who really lived and he actually
sat down for like 10 years to like
figure out how to like solve all human
rationality God bless his autistic Soul
you know he failed obviously but you
know you can see that the idea is not
new in this regard I know but there's
this interesting Paradox I mean Sam
Harris
um a lot of people have gone off him
recently because he has
you know they cite Trump derangement
syndrome and he was very very
paternalistic over the covid Fiasco and
I think he actually gave an example on
his show of like you know look the the
meat is an example the meteor is coming
towards the planet and I can see the
media other people can't see the meter
the meteor so you need to listen to what
I'm saying and so so there's that
there's this one maybe actually we do
need to listen but then on on the other
hand as you were just alluding to it's
possible that there's a kind of tunnel
vision or almost um path you know
pathology uh going on here which is
weirdly making them not rational no of
course you should never believe an
argument on Authority alone and like
obviously so like the whole thing is
that the existential risk argument
should not be complicated if you need an
authority figure to ex to believe it I
think you're the irrational one it's a
very simple argument the data is not the
thinking is not dependent on oh Elias or
said it or posterum said it or Stuart
Russell said or whatever I actually
really I mean of course in practice it
is because a lot of people do form their
opinions this way this is why a lot of
people try to get you know more
academics and such to publicly
acknowledge the problem and in practice
this is a lot of how the problem will
actually be addressed because humans
like their Authority and their status
and so on but really the arguments
aren't that hard like
I really dislike how like
ideas such as historicality thesis or
similar convergence or like seen as
these weird complex philosophical points
because I do not consider them to be
complicated at all I think they'll be
obvious okay Like Instrumental
conversion is just hey you need
resources to do things right yeah so if
you build a thing that's trying to do
things yeah it will try to get resources
yeah that's the argument there you go
you've understood both Roman philosophy
congratulations that's it let's talk
about alignment
first of all I mean maybe you should
start by sketching out because you've
been on this unbelievable Journey since
we spoke last time um on on the podcast
you're now the CEO of conjecture and
your mission is alignment although you
are doing some other stuff on on the
side because it's it's a business so why
don't we start with that and how hard is
alignment great questions I always my
favorite topic
so alignment so my favorite different
people Define the word alignment
differently
um and I like the definition which is
alignment is the the field of study to
solve the problem that
turning that makes it so that turning on
an advanced AI is a good idea rather
than a bad idea I like this very blunt
pragmatic definition it isn't everything
that needs to be done so that if you
click the Run button on in super
intelligence a good thing happens and
not a bad thing
and so of course this leads to more
specific things so for example Eliezer
has now
um stopped calling it AI alignment he
now calls it AI not kill everyone ISM
so to focus on it's not about
it's not about any specific like thing
or like or like specific Direction
affecting vision of how it has to look
or like how it's just like can we get
the things to do anything good at all
that is not immediately obviously
terribly bad so and the part of the
alignment question and like the like
field is of course is assumption that by
default things will not go well is it or
at least that there are many many
systems that if you do run them it would
be really bad
so one of the like you know Step Zero of
like alignment is kind of like just like
none of us and like would ever think
that every intelligence is naturally
good I think this is a thing that
everyone will agree with like at least
hypothetically you could always build a
bad AGI that does bad things or that
harms people or whatever the next
question is How likely are these to
happen in practice because like you know
surely no one would want to build AI
that hurts people right so then you have
to talk about things such as
instrumental convergence which is just
the observation that if you tell a
system a powerful intelligence system to
accomplish a goal any goal it very often
will require some amount of resources it
will require money or computer or energy
or friends or political influence
whatever and then it will try to
accomplish the acquire those so you know
another one of those is potentially
self-preservation is that you know if I
tell my robot to fetch me coffee and
then I try to turn the robot off well
the robot will then simply reason if I'm
shut off I cannot bring you coffee
therefore you may not shut me down can I
push back on that time it's so yeah
there are two very important Concepts in
this line of reasoning so there's the
orthogonality thesis which is this idea
that um a very I don't know like um a
very intelligent AI might be solely
focused on the pursuit of something
trivial and and then there's this idea
of instrumental convergence as you're
saying that I think that's the famous
example of The Cauldron and in the
pursuit of filling up The Cauldron to
precisely the same level
um the AI might be worried about being
turned off so you know let's kill the
person who runs the cauldron room or
something like that
and my intuition is that
if if it were actually intelligent it
wouldn't you know would it not realize
that oh this thing I'm doing is really
stupid
why do you have sex
it's really stupid
I mean it's a good question
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah you've uh you've really got me
there
yeah yeah do you remember that um Jordan
Peterson interview with um Kathy Newman
yeah when she was absolutely dumbfounded
but yeah so this is what it feels like
from the inside to have arbitrary goals
is that you like things and they feel
correct they feel like good because they
feel like things you're trying to
accomplish this is what it feels like
from the inside to be an agent who's
optimizing for some goals because
organality thesis just says like you
know
you know some humans like sex with women
some humans like sex with men and that's
completely with Oregon they could also
like I don't know feet or whatever right
you know it's like we already see this
in humans you just like go on a
porn website you see orthogonality it's
all its Glory you know it's like yeah I
mean I'm obviously joking but like you
know it's a good metaphor in the sense
that humans already have you know not a
full orthogonality there's a lot of
things that you know no human will
actually wants I'm like bizarre thing
whatever even so so some very some very
artistic people have some very weird
interests but
it's it's fundamentally it's trying to
separate the idea of the optimization of
the intelligence from the goal is that a
a powerful Optimizer can do whatever
it's it's not convergent it's not like
all people end up agreeing that oh
actually women are beautiful and men
like no no like some people like men and
some people like women and that's just
how it is there's no right or wrong it's
just a preference and similarly there is
an AI might just have preferences it
might just like things being blue and
then it just wants to paint everything
blue and another AI might want to paint
everything green and there's and there's
eight eyes might meet each other and
they might have a philosophical debate
for a trillion years but they're never
going to agree because you know one of
them like green my life blue there are
things that are less
um
less arbitrary so it's like kind of like
what we talked about a little bit about
like there's like Dutch picking and
stuff like this is that those two AIS if
they want to win they do have to do a
lot of things they have to gain power
they have to like gather resources they
have to be in in you know non-hackable
they have to be consistent they have to
you know do probability well they have
to you know they have to do all these
things those are like non-optional in
the sense that they are optional if
you're the most powerful but if you're
not if the green and the blue you know
AGI are fighting each other they're
gonna be forced to become more coherent
and more powerful and more intelligent
because otherwise the other ones
okay but but to summarize it a little
bit AI alignment is really really hard
because in The Cauldron example we spoke
about this last time so we won't go over
it again but
um the reward function would just become
more and more and more complex because
you'd be saying oh and you can't do that
and you can't do that and you can't do
that right so yeah that's one exactly
and you were also saying it's a little
bit like we can't really test this I
mean yeah we can test it and we can
think about it but it's only really when
we launch the thing that we find out and
just like a rocket it might explode and
cause a lot of collateral damage yeah so
those are those are the core of why it's
hard yeah so at the core Prime it's hard
I think so I think it's really important
to be clear like do not think it's an
unsolvable problem there's nothing in
the laws of physics that prevents humans
from just building an AGI that does
exactly what we want that you know
builds a beautiful Utopia whatever and
when you click a button and we just lean
back okay we did it boys there's nothing
no reason we can't do that the question
is just whether we will actually do it
because it's an actually hard problem so
there's many ways in which the problem
is hard like the ones you just described
are are two great points is the one is
just currently we just don't know how to
do it even in theory like we don't know
how to write a reward function or how to
write a system that can like do
arbitrary complex things you know things
are more complicated than what humans
can do
and then but then we'll still like let's
all be shut down or you know will not
harm humans or whatever because we it's
a problem with consequentialism again
it's like how do you how do you build a
consequentialist that like of health is
these like super complicated properties
how do you convey this especially with
neural networks right like God forbid
like you know no one knows how these
things work like I give you a RL system
I say hey make this RL system please uh
never you know never touch blue objects
it's like
what how do I even do that like I can
train it on some data sure but like will
that like convince it I don't know and
then there's the rocket problem as you
describe in the sense that
if we build a very very very powerful AI
system very very powerful optimizers and
we get it wrong even once that might be
it
okay but then we get to this thing that
the exciting thing about AI as it is now
is that it's emergentist it's learning
but you look at a lot of reinforcement
learning systems from deepmind and so on
there's an incredible amount of reward
hacking going on so it's almost like
we're go five people again when we talk
about alignment and we talk about reward
shaping and all of this kind of stuff
which seems disappointing I mean I did
actually speak with Pedro Domingos the
other day and he was saying that oh you
know we're not don't be silly Tim we're
not going to have like one utility
function or whatever we're gonna have um
a pan a play of functions and we're
going to meta learn them
um I mean what do you think I mean yeah
in practice I expect that's what it's
going to look like as well to be clear
when I talk about utility function I
usually mean it as a metaphor I don't
mean there's literally a line of python
code that determines what the thing does
that also runs into something called the
pointerest problem which we can talk
about in a second
um
it's probably going to be alerted
utility function of some kind that's
kind of what rhf is rhf is a learned
utility function in that you have a
learner a reward model which learns from
examples some hypothetical functions you
don't know how to write which includes
what humans want GPT output to look like
and then you optimize for that function
and this can run into many problems if
if there wasn't obvious the biggest
problem
with there's like two big problems with
this the obvious one is just
why the do you expect that thing to
learn what you wanted to learn like like
you don't know what it learned it
learned something you know and maybe
like on distribution looks like what
what you want but Auto distribution who
knows as we saw I talked about like the
mode collapse uh stuff where you train
the you train your model on like some
like human preference date and suddenly
it thinks numbers should work
differently like that's obviously not
what you wanted it to do but it is what
it learned and how would you know
because our Theory and our ability to
understand and interpret these neural
networks is so terrible it's not just
that we can't understand the policy we
also can't understand the reward
function so we're adding more black
boxes now into the system so if anything
it's gotten worse yeah so what do we do
and that is an excellent question if I
had an answer I would be a very happy
man today
the truth of the matter is is that I
don't know but I have some guesses I
have some directions of what to go where
to go and what to do so
it's importantly again I think this is a
solvable problem I've talked a lot about
like Theory I've talked about like
understanding of like constructing
things from scratch or like
understanding things and or like
decompiling neural networks so I think
these are all promising directions so if
I could like push any perspective viewer
into one direction of research it would
be mechanistic interpretability and this
is kind of like
a subfield of like interpretability and
neural networks that's like focus in
particular on like reverse engineering
circuits like really understanding what
things do internally being able to like
you know re-implement them from scratch
or like edit them like stuff like that
yeah I mean could I um drill into that a
little bit so I mean I'm interested in
interpretability but we can't even
interpret an eighth note a neural
network or a tiny decision I mean you
know like a an ensemble of decision
trees it's unintelligible right it's
beyond our cognitive Horizon and that's
why whenever we reason about
intelligence for example we always look
at Behavior well in fact it's the same
thing with software testing Frameworks
now how do unit tests work they test
Behavior you know we don't care about
what happens I mean yeah maybe we do a
little bit but but it's always Behavior
so how do you get past that limit of of
our cognitive Horizon yeah so there's a
there's a good question and there's part
of that I agree with and partly I don't
agree with so
Chris Ola for example and his group have
reverse engineered like basically all of
inceptionette and like or like a large
part of the inceptionette and you can
just look at the filters you could look
exactly oh this is a dog detector and
you just you look at it it's just a dog
some of them we don't know like 30 of
the neurons were still like I don't know
what they do and and if you remove them
the thing breaks so obviously they do
something but like there's a significant
amount we're like ah these neurons here
form a circle detector it's like you can
directly follow the algorithm you can
even remove the neurons or rewrite them
in Python and then like insert that
Python program where those neurons are
and the network keeps working so okay
but a bit on on that so the same thing
so in intelligence people have a
functionalist conception so they say I'm
going to take a complex thing I'm going
to reduce it down to functions so it
does planning it does reasoning it does
perception and similarly you can take a
neural network and you can take a slice
and you and you can kind of draw a
boundary around this certainly you know
if you look at um the human brain for
example you've probably seen the
schematic of the visual system and V1
and V2 and so on and that's a really low
resolution I understand it it does so
much more than that sure I'm not saying
that understanding one circuit is
sufficient obviously where you have to
push for it is you have to understand
the whole thing is that you have to at
some point you have to or understand
enough about it that you can put bounds
on things that you can put understanding
on things like maybe you can say okay
um I have no freaking clue what happens
if it goes out of this distribution but
in this distribution I can promise it
will never output class 100 something
like that like that is a useful property
another important thing well just just
on that because that's very similar with
when we talk about reasoning in neural
networks we we again we test for
Behavior but we test on on a huge amount
of examples and it seems to extrapolate
outside of the training support so we
kind of say okay well I believe that
this thing's going to work robustly and
is it the same thing as saying okay I've
developed this framework of
understanding so this circuit does this
and now I believe it will behave in this
way all of the time and is that is that
too much of a jump so the difference is
empiricism versus theory is like Okay
um
these for example statements are
infinite primes is not a statement that
is empirical it is a statement we make
because of theoretical grounds the way
we Define numbers we can make a proof
that proves that there are infinite
Primes
so I I now have a guarantee about the
out of distribution behavior of my
primary function I know it will always
find more primes this is an interesting
property now this is of course a very
elegant example this is not how I expect
this won't work in practice with like
neural networks I don't expect in
practice we're going to use like proof
Checkers on neural networks not how it's
gonna work for practice it's gonna be
like probabilistic it's going to be like
messy it's gonna be like whatever but I
think
I think people are kind of like some
people
um kind of like give up before even
trying like I feel like some people are
like
um we'll just like throw their hands up
in the air and be like oh this is
obviously impossible I'm not even gonna
try I'm like man like at least give it a
shot come on and like every time we try
to like understand like these systems
I'm surprised by how much signal you can
find how much you can be like oh okay I
can actually understand how that thing's
implemented or like okay I can see what
it's doing here I don't fully understand
it but like you know 80 of it I'm like
okay is doing this kind of operation and
where I hope this will lead in the long
term also is that we can also then use
this kind of knowledge this
understanding of how these systems do
things to build systems that are cleaner
so
I think alignment in the Gen most
General sense is definitely impossible
if an alien comes around from outer
space and hands your USB drive with
agi.exe do not run it
don't
don't matter how much analysis you do on
it no matter how much you you know scan
it for viruses or whatever don't run it
an alien built it who knows what's in
that thing it's like of course a smart
alien can always trick you so if you
just have a random AGI from somewhere
yeah I don't think it's linable I don't
think you can align an arbitrary AI but
what I do the reason I think we can
succeed with this problem is we get to
build the AI we get to actually
construct this we got to pick the
training data we get the trick the pick
the algorithms we get to pick the
architecture we get to pick all these
different parameters and I think where
we should where I'm most hopeful like if
I Envision a good future where we like
build a great AI that does what we want
it to do the way they expect it to go is
that in the future well the way we do
like training the way we do like
building is not just LOL The Mao you
take a neural network and throw a bunch
of data at it and just like hope it
generalizes but more like you have like
a much finer understanding of like what
does it do what order does it learn it
like you like factor out parts of the
network or you like you like you like me
put like do it unit test some like sub
parts circuits or whatever or you like
import things that you already like know
about or like I don't know something
like that but we use some new methods
that are having been developed I don't
know what these methods will look like
in practice that allow us to build clean
support where you can just way more
understand ah okay here it's doing this
and I understand this sufficiently
theoretically well that I'm not going to
be surprised or what happens yeah I like
this idea of building cleaner neural
networks I mean there was a great video
by Grant Sanderson recently where he was
talking about some
um some fractal pattern
um in in some area of mathematics and he
kind of visualized it and I had all of
these you know like the boundary of
chaos and it seemed actually very
regular but they were like these weird
regions of irregularity and you can zoom
in on it and then and it would just just
become more and more weird on the
boundary and I think the um uh the the
concept of a cellular automaton is quite
a good way to think about this so that's
kind of how we train neural networks
they're emergentists so we we are
nudging the thing in a lower level
domain and you get all of this emergent
complexity and yes we can change the
lower level rules to regularize the
emergent domain but there'll still be
all of these weird boundaries in all of
these regions that we can't possibly
test because the space is too large so
like I guess like this just feels like
that's the reason for my skepticism I
mean yeah absolutely to be clear if we
do this by default I don't expect this
to work I I totally expect that the old
methods we will by default use to build
the systems will be completely
uninterpretable and like way too
complicated and we'll I will or rather
I'll expect we're going to interpret
like 80 of them and be like 20 is
probably fine and it's not fine like the
like the 20 will contain like all the
crazy super intelligence but it's going
to look like noise I expect like I
expect if I showed you an ATI from the
future and you looked at the weights
like mostly would look like noise to you
you'd be like
this does and then if you like turn it
off for some reason everything breaks
like you know just like change one way
slightly and or something you remove the
high frequency noise and suddenly
everything else working
and but I don't think this is
necessary I don't think you have to
build AGI this way I think this is a way
it can go but I think there are ways to
build these systems that where you just
avoid these chaotic Properties or you
bound them in some way or you like you
like limit their influence on things you
limit the coupling you limit the
whatever again these are methods I'm
making a prediction I'm making a
prediction about a future feel of
science that basically hasn't even been
started yet would you entertain the
possibility that the the kind of the
chaotic nature is somehow a necessary
condition for Asia so there is a part
that is actually necessary like
obviously so like obviously obviously so
which is that any sufficient
intelligence system has to be coupled
with the environment the environment
isn't chaotic yeah so obviously a
sufficiently intelligent system must be
uninterpretable it has to be because if
you could interpret it it would mean you
understand more about reality than you
actually do so actually doing
interpretability on a very powerful
system will not just be understanding
the network it would also mean to
understand the environment so if you
have an AGI that's interacting with the
outside world you also have to have a
really good Theory of physics you have
to have a really good theory about of
upticks and sociology and everything
interacts with you know if you have a
system that interacts with the economy
you know that like trade the stock
market you have to understand the stock
market to understand the system
interacting with it because you know
it's a part of the whole dynamic system
right but isn't isn't that the problem
so a lot of um by the way you know the
the the the rationalists in philosophy
so the different types of different type
of rationalists like Thomas Nago and
Chomsky we spoke to Chomsky he said that
many things in the world are just beyond
our cognitive Horizon he gives the
example of the prime number maze uh you
know which rats can't solve because rats
just don't have the cognitive ability to
do that no one understands economics
right and Chomsky says that physicists
are meter readers and um he he cites
physics as being almost like this very
reductionist view of a much more complex
reality and we just kind of take
observables and and we create
intelligible theories to understand the
world that we live in so isn't isn't
that cognitive Horizon going to stop us
from building interpretable AI if we in
one shot build systems that are so far
beyond a cognitive Horizon you can't
understand them and then we turn them on
we die
obviously if we
can we build systems that are 0.5 or 1.5
argument Horizons and we just develop
much much better theories to understand
them now that's more that's a more
interesting question and if we have a
1.5 system can we use it to build a 2.5
system and if we have a 2.5 system can
we use that to build a five system and
if you have a five system can you
understand a 10 system I don't have an
answer to this question but it doesn't
seem obviously impossible to me it seems
obviously probably possible that if you
just get a thousand X AGI draws from the
sky you're scared you can't understand
this thing it's you will never
understand this thing we will never ever
understand this thing and if we turn it
on that's it and game over but if we
build a much more that's why that's why
I'm focusing on this like we get to
build the AI
this so this is a common conversation to
have with people where people are like
wow Conor why aren't you like happy
about like scaling laws it makes like
our Intel like predictable like no no it
doesn't at all it's it's we don't know
how to predict how smart AIS are this is
a big problem with a line problem is
hard it's people sometimes will be like
oh it's fine we'll just wait until it's
like just below danger and then we'll
stop and I'm like first of all LOL
imagined corporations just stopping B
how do you know you're just one step
away from the bad thing before it's
already too late how would you know and
sometimes people like you know hand wave
something's on the scaling laws I'm like
okay and which loss does it become super
intelligent
hey please show me the number like no of
course not that's very silly it's the
ability to predict how
powerful system will be is dependent not
only on the agent you're studying but
also on its environment so you also have
to have a very very strong theory about
the environment interacting with and
because the environment is the universe
and we don't have super strong
predictive theories of the entire
universe we can't predict this kind of
stuff and this is why this is at the
core of why I think this is hard
I think if we could all agree to just
like
I slow the down let's just like go
only like teeny micro steps until we've
like developed as much Theory as humanly
possible and then we take one more micro
step and then we develop as much
theories humanly possible and we take
one more step yeah I think we'd be fine
probably maybe not you know maybe one of
those microsteps still kills us but it's
like possible but like currently we're
not even trying like currently we're
just like let's just make as big a steps
as possible as often and as fast as
possible and just see what happens a
little
yeah it's really interesting because um
in a way you're like a mystery to me
because you are very bullish and and
accepted I mean you're worried about the
future but you're very accepting of the
the technology Revolution that that's
going to happen over the next few years
and I guess like my skepticism is having
just done a show on cell for example I
know you don't agree with so but he
makes an argument that agency and
intentionality are very important and he
actually thinks biology is is required
but when I spoke to Pedro Domingo's
about this he said no Tim that's
ridiculous it's like you know you you
have a grain of sand and it turns into a
purse you have the starting conditions
and I guess you might argue that AI
becomes really dangerous when you have
this reflexivity so now it's going to
the internet it can compile code it can
run programs it can interact it can
improve itself and all the rest of it so
I guess like the question to you is what
do you think are the most dangerous
steps maybe you don't want to talk about
this you don't want to talk about this
yeah if I knew how to build if I knew
how to build a dangerous AGI I would not
tell you
and presumably you do
no comment
okay okay so we haven't really spoken
about your your journey at conjecture
maybe we should do that now yeah I'd
love to talk about that so conjecture is
the accompany me and my two co-founder
is founded earlier this year we kind of
officially kind of really got started
going in March and so we're still pretty
young
conjecture grew a lot out of illusory AI
which is you know the open source
Collective I I used to be one of the
co-founders of for a long time great
experience there but ultimately I start
to run into some bottlenecks with Lou 3i
you know I love doing work in blue 3i we
did a lot of cool projects and such but
at some point you know working in a
Luther Ai and a was kind of like imagine
you were hurting cats but the cats also
were the smartest people you've ever met
and had crippling ADHD that's what we're
working at Luther which is you know
experience but also
if you ever want to get anything done it
was it was a pain so turns out at some
point if you want to actually get people
to do things especially boring things
you have to pay them
so around comes conjecture so you raise
some initial money so conjecture is a
for-profit company do you mind saying
how much
um I think initial round was like
11 or 12 million so it was a pretty big
round and thank you so much developer uh
lovely investors who really took a weird
bet on us
um so it was it was a really unusual bet
I think for because I'm not sure if our
investors you know fully by the
alignment thing but they buy some of it
so uh they both so could you expand that
they buy some of it I think they're more
they're just not as sure as I am so I've
talked to like uh Nat Friedman who's our
main investor I've talked to many times
about this topic yeah I think there's I
think we're we're in many things we're
not uncertain about other things I think
more and more I believe the tech world's
coming around to my point of view which
um you know it's not a surprise
interesting and so I recognize Nat
Friedman are there any other names I
would recognize Carlson Brothers
um Daniel gross those are like the main
beginning semesters okay okay so yeah
um we're very very thankful for them
taking uh taking a risk on us and you
know it's been great great time so far
all these people by the way really
wonderful people really really smart
people it's been a real pleasure working
with them yeah so it's very unusual
because it's not the usual crowd you'd
get like alignment funding from uh which
is you know because these are not
rationalists these are not rationalists
yes I mean maybe we could explore that
but also we could explore
um I mean your your you're just a guy
you're very similar to me but you're
very honest you're very technical and
you've been thrust into being the CEO
position basically of of this of this
Enterprise yeah and I can't even imagine
how difficult that must have been
it's it's very true in the sense that
this is the hardest I've ever worked in
my life this is the hardest job I've
ever had I've never been challenged as
much in my life it's there's been you
know people I remember it's very funny
before I started this I would sometimes
see like CEOs on on Twitter you know was
talking about all they have these you
know ADR work visually works and I was
always like
I always thought they were lying I
always thought like he was a fake job
like oh come on like how hard can it
really be uh it's fine Well turns out I
can confirm it is actually very hard and
it's very very challenging
but also in a sense
I'm not at the time in my life it's just
kind of like I feel like this is
actually the job I was supposed to be
doing it's like I've really it was very
tough and I had to learn a lot and I've
changed I feel like I've lived 2.5
lifetimes over the last year but I was I
was going to ask you about that now the
weird thing is you still seem like the
same Conor I know and loved from before
but
how has it changed you oh it has changed
me
um it's changed in many ways
um one of the most interesting things we
talk about I think the biggest emotional
shift that it really elicited in me is
that I'm much much more tolerant of
tension and like failure and chaos and
and so on I used to be a lot more
concerned about what other people
thought about me and like nothing goes
wrong they don't you know that you know
I want people to be you know Harmony and
not for the problems and I've just
become much more tolerant of just like
now if you try to do hard things it's
not going to be comfortable it's going
to be a bumpy ride and the bumps don't
stop and you just have to get used to
that the go you know when it used to be
that if there was a bump I would
immediately try to fix the bump that's
immediately attention shifts the bump
how do I solve this but I'm like nope
this isn't how many bumps are there uh
okay does not not lethal it's fine and
getting that like level of like
emotional just like acceptance of it
rather than fighting it
I think it has been really really
valuable also I'm just like less afraid
to say things that might upset other
people and those afraid of conflict I'm
less afraid of people disagreeing with
me or like getting into fights with me
it's not that I was afraid of that it
was just it took energy out of me it's
just like I could fight someone and I
would do it but afterwards I'd feel like
tired be like you know I'd feel like bad
I I it would take a lot out of me and
now I've gotten much better and that it
just doesn't take energy out of me I'm
still not happy about it but it just you
know also I'll go home I'll have dinner
no sleep and then the next day I'll work
harder and it's just fine
so that's like the biggest emotional
difference
I think the biggest like
thing that I've learned
um
the biggest thing I've learned is
um it's funny I think this is I think
Eliezer is actually the person that said
this to me in a different context like
there are no adults in the room
this is
ever like this is really hard to explain
to people until you've experienced it
but
everything in the entire world is so
inefficient nothing works no one knows
what they're doing there is no master
plan everything is chaos it's
wild it is unimaginable like how much
you can do as even it's like one person
or a small number of people by just
actually really trying very hard
it is crazy how inefficient the market
is it is crazy how slow and uncreative
big companies are it is crazy how much
how easy it is to just like go talk to
politicians and they will listen to you
it's it's wild the amount of influence
the amount of Leverage you can gain as
an individual or even as a small group
of people by just really actually trying
and working very hard and being you know
decently and decently charismatic it's
crazy yeah I mean there's a few things
to explore that I mean first of all we
could touch on what you just alluded to
which was that even before in a life
that AIU had an insane amount of
influence well beyond what would be
expected for basically a bunch of Fairly
Young Folks just kind of playing on
their computers at home but you were
maybe you're in the right place at the
right time you were just on on the the
start of an exciting technology Transit
so there's that I can also speak to this
I mean I've recently
um I've got a startup on the CTO with
with Keith who runs mlst and just being
completely honest with you I came from
the corporate world and I was in a sort
of you know mid-level senior position
and everything was great um I was
respected I had you know a kind of
because we all want Authority and
respect and all these good things
everything was very organized and mature
and stupidly I thought going into a
startup company you know I I would I
would be somebody and as you I think
you're kind of pointing to this and you
can expand on it but actually when you
started a company
it's so right when Ellie as I said there
are no adults in the room it was like we
had all regressed to being children
again we were arguing about absolutely
everything part of it is about the
Dynamics of you know like you know
becoming established and agreeing on
sacred cows and lots of friction and so
on it was actually one of the most
stressful and miserable experiences of
my life and we finally converged and it
takes a long time to converge and you
learn a lot of lessons that is that a
similar experience for you
so it wasn't quite that much because we
already thought ourselves as children
and so when I said there were no adults
in the room I didn't just mean us I
meant in the world it's like I expected
other people to be adults but I know oh
wait they're also all children it's like
I knew I was a kid
you know I know my friends were kids I
know we were trying something you know
we're trying to move from kid to adult
that's like we knew this is our us
moving from kid to adult but then we
noticed wait where are the adults once
we started to like understand how the
world works and like how other things
work and how people do things and like
why they don't do things and such and
we're like oh oh interesting and like
how much people would tell us that like
oh you can't do X and then like why
can't we do accidentally well if x was
possible someone would have already done
that and then we're like well has
someone tried it and they're like well I
don't know surely someone has and then
we try it and it works because no one
has tried
it's just
so
unbelievably much about what people tell
themselves as possible stories
impossible it's just completely fake
like the market isn't efficient like the
efficient American hypothesis is just
wrong it's just not true of reality
there's like very small areas where the
market is efficient you know if you want
to like you know trade stocks you know
as an individual investors against like
a large hedge fund on average yes you're
sure you know or like you know
weird crazy derivatives or whatever yeah
you're don't do that you know or if
you want to be I know a Hollywood star
yeah that's hard like because it's an
adversarial environment don't try it
stupid but
so much
so much of reality is so absurdly
inefficient no one is trying
if if I give one piece of advice to any
smart people listening if you're
decently smart and decent creative and
you've come up with an idea and you're
like well this should obviously work
will someone else probably already tried
it they probably have it go try it well
the key word is the word obvious because
what you realize and I think what you're
alluding to is that it might be obvious
to you and surprisingly it's not obvious
to other people yep very true and um I
had this realization because in the
corporate world there was an incubator
and I was in I actually got to run one
of the startups for a year and all of a
sudden my mindset completely shifted and
my boss at the time Justin he said Tim
you know we're just tracking ourselves
out of the Stone Age and there's so much
software that hasn't been written yet
and exactly as you say you know some of
the some of the problem is it's just a
lack of imagination it was easy for us
to raise money like surprisingly easy we
didn't raise as much as you did but we
still raised to quite a bit of money and
I didn't realize how inefficient these
large companies are I mean I'm very
impressed that open AI are churning all
of this stuff out but certainly doing
what we're doing
over at meta you know um John Carmack
just wrote a note he just left meta and
he said I am exasperated nothing gets
done here this is a show so many
bad decisions so many committees and the
truth is as you said if you're creative
and reasonably intelligent
um because I don't want I don't want the
charge of old privilege and all the
restaurants there is some privilege I
think we're both privileged and lucky in
many ways but
um it's actually remarkably easy just to
build something because all you need are
the skills to write code
yep creativity and ability to write code
and just actually shipping actually
doing things it is is really crazy it is
and like you mentioned earlier how like
a Lutheran I kind of already got lucky
and I had this like weird scenario where
I suddenly had all this weird leverage
and the question always in the back of
my mind was did I just get lucky or did
I actually do something impressive or
and like is the world actually
inefficient because like why did no one
else build illusory AI it wasn't that
hard it was really fun there's a lot of
other smart people that could have done
it you know and so
now that I've you know now that they're
going to start up again and like I'm
like oh wait no there's like actually no
one like very few people are trying and
there's like all this like free energy
all around there's all these like
opportunities that you just like have to
like just do well let me let me push on
that then because I would like you in
your own words to describe what it is
you have
from my perspective you had an
incredible following I mean I'm still on
the Luther AI Discord and you would have
these community events when you would
talk and loads of people would join and
everybody just listened to what you were
saying you have the incredible
orientation skills and you also have
something which is quite common in CEOs
which is just like this incredible
confidence and vision and people got on
board with it so it would is that a fair
summation do you think that's part of it
that was definitely part of it that's
something I uh I actually didn't realize
for a long time I was actually very
funny so uh I didn't realize that I was
relatively charismatic for a long time I
like kind of knew it but because it's
actually very funny why I'm charismatic
because I am nerded right I am I am in a
bit of an I am more than a bit of an
autist at heart you know and but it's
very funny I never I never thought of
myself as autistic when I was younger I
never got diagnosed when I was a
statistic as when I was young because I
was really good at talking I was really
good at it and the thing is like I got
so obsessed with like being good at
storytelling because I loved it so much
I had my dad's fantasy author I love
storytelling and I loved D and like
telling people things and like
convincing eventually as a kid I almost
like 12 or something I was like I
noticed man I really like talking a lot
and but like it's kind of a dick move
like to always talk all the time so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna become the
best at talking so other people want to
listen to me so I can just never shut up
so I explicitly reasoned this as a kid
like okay I'm gonna skip practice I'm
gonna get really good so yeah I just
like got really good at it and I just
like and that was really valuable
because we were speaking about this
before we hit the record button and yeah
you're really good at talking but you're
very authentic so it you really
passionately believe because it's
obvious it it reeks from every orifice
that you really believe in in what
you're saying and people really get on
board with that there's a real kind of
like buzz around it because we were
saying it before we press the record
button I actually said I don't like
interviewing CEOs
um actually I've interviewed a couple of
really good ones so I don't don't let
this be a reflection but there are loads
of folks that have reached out to be on
the podcast even like Eric Schmidt for
example and I didn't reply because I
knew it'd be a boring
conversation and the reason for that is
I just I hate fakeness and in the in the
corporate world in particular and if
you're the CEO my brother is the CEO of
my company and you know it it's like
he's an automaton right it's it's just
it's a really boring conversation yeah
so but you don't have that yeah weird
like that yeah I don't think so I I
think so very well thank you but I think
the the Genesis of that is something
different so I think that the ability to
like tell stories well and to like you
know be charismatic and have like good
that kind of stuff there's a lot of
those learned I think what you're
describing is
um I think one of the traits I would I
more like about myself or like or like
um like for for me like being good at
talking feels like a skill it's like oh
you're good at basketball I'm like yeah
thank you I am good at basketball like I
played it a lot as a kid you know and
but it doesn't feel like you know
somewhat unusual thing I feel like a lot
of people could learn this if they just
practice like some people think I have
like a magical ability to be good at
talking like no I just practice like I
just practiced a lot as a kid and I I I
you know I told stories and I wrote
stories and I tried to convince you know
tell people stories and entertain them
so a lot of it is practice
but when you describe and I think you're
correct about this is like this like um
there's another thing as a kid which was
different again it's very funny in
retrospect if I look back at my teenage
me like how autistic I was and how I
didn't realize it I had this thing where
I had terrible insomnia as a kid where
like uh if I went to bed it would take
like three hours until I fall asleep
every single night my whole life hey
it's gotten better now but like but it
was very funny because as a teenager I
was like oh yeah thinking time yeah but
I could like I would like go to bed or
really giddy every night and spend like
three hours just like thinking really
hard about like my life about what I
want to accomplish about my morality
like what does it mean to be a good man
what does it mean to do to be honest and
to do the right thing and I was obsessed
with this I'm obsessed with this like
what how can I do the most good how can
I help the most people how could I like
you know be the best person et cetera et
cetera I was obsessed with this question
and I would think about this every
single day for like my entire teenage
years and what I really found was in
many sense is that
a lot of things that are holding people
back from like doing good things and
like doing the things I want to do are
actually
not so much that they're be they're not
smart enough or they're like lacking
something if they're being stupid
and what I mean by that is is that
so much about what makes me now like
more competent than I was when I was
like a teenager some of that is learning
new things you know having new
information new skills whatever you know
but a huge amount of it is just like
unlearning stupid things and like
Stories We Tell ourselves and like
stories I told myself and like
inhibitions and fears about like like
being honest like but the honesty thing
is like this is very common thing where
like like some people are like oh Connor
responders or you're so brave you see
these things I'm like well okay yeah why
don't you do it too like oh no I can't
I'm like just just just do it like no no
no then these bad things will happen
like what bad things like oh people not
like you know like whatever like man
just do the thing just do the thing and
so there's like ability to like
it's like this like beautiful this
little thing I love about like autistic
cultures is like this ability to just
like just see the thing for what it is
just kind of like cut through the social
stuff just like kind of be like focused
on what actually matters and that's what
I ultimately care about it says like
what my what I got out of this like you
know autistic Obsession there's like
almost OCD level Obsession of like
scrupulosity of like caring about what
is the right thing to do what should I
do how should I do it the result was
ultimately just like this clearing like
it wasn't like my brain became more
complicated it became more simple I'm
more like oh okay I don't actually care
about all of these things like those are
like I don't really care about this but
this is something I truly care about so
I'm just gonna like cut away everything
else I'm gonna focus on what I actually
care about yeah and that's the the I
mean the tunnel vision is is a feature
of of CEOs and and because what you're
talking about and in a sense you could
see it as a negative because you've
become entrenched so you said I I've
I've kind of converged this is the Basin
I want to be in and now I'm
progressively filtering out everything
so now you and you're a voracious reader
when you were younger as well so you
were in this kind of like knowledge
acquisition phase I mean you told me
before you know you read for example
Society of Mind by Minsky you you've
read a lot of stuff you had loads and
loads of book recommendations for me but
now you're a busy guy you're a
busy guy you've converged and also uh
maybe you can talk about a lot of people
make demands on your time now and you
presumably you have to start filtering
things out and you have to deal with a
lot of flawed human beings so how has
you know in this new regime how has that
changed absolutely great question and I
think you you really hit on the head in
that
there's one regret I have I I wish I
would have like done more things as a
kid because I had more time back then
and you know I did it's like I was
surprisingly like not that clever as a
kid it was like you know it's like I
don't know I feel like I was stupid as a
kid I I didn't really read that much I
only really started reading like after I
was 18 and like as a kid I didn't really
read that much I didn't really do that
much I kind of just like thought a lot
you know I just kind of like
do thinking really hard but I didn't
really gather evidence about reality and
that like definitely held me back for a
long time so like I'm now at the point
and like where the difference is between
now and a year ago is bits of evidence
that collected about reality from
actually doing things in the real world
is that I've I think for years now I
mean probably since like my early 20s
I've actually been held back I didn't
realize this but I was held back not by
my knowledge or my intelligence I was I
was academic enough I was educated
enough I was you know verbal enough but
I was held back by not trying things in
the real world not talking to people not
doing business not building things not
failing not meeting new people not
traveling not doing all this and so
and that's regard it's definitely the
case that I don't have time to read tons
of books anymore and that does lose me
some things because I did you know
especially my like later 20s like I was
like 25 or something I spent like all
day reading every single day just all
day
and that was very helpful and that's but
I'm not in an overhang like I've read
too much
now I need to gather other kinds of
information and over the last year
I've learned so much from interacting
with reality from meeting people from
going to Brussels and talking to
politicians I'm building a product from
trying to raise money from all these
kinds of things so
in that regard I've learned different
things there's different kinds of
evidence that I've been able to gather
more effectively and if the government
better and more effective at Gathering
evidence so
a word that keeps getting brought up by
conjecture that other people I think
don't use or use differently than we do
is good epistemology yeah I think
epistemology so the way it is not I'm
sure the philosophers will argue with me
what the correct definition is but one
of the way I think about epistemology
having good epistemology is kind of the
ability to like
come into a new field or a new area
where you know nothing about it and you
know how to gain the evidence you need
to gain to build the theories you need
to build to succeed at what you want to
succeed at kind of like you know up the
meta hierarchy and this is like a very
Universal skill it's like a super
Universal skill and like I think it's
not it wasn't obvious to me for a long
time this is a skill you can practice it
was like you can practice a field you
can go into a topic and you can work on
it but it was clear to me that you can
practice the skill of getting good at
skills but that's actually obviously
true now in retrospect
yeah and I want to tease that apart a
little bit so at first you were saying
and by the way people like Jan McCune
make the opposite argument they think
that AGI should be mostly observational
rather than interactive but um I agree
with you that there's only so much you
can learn from reading books because
what you're doing is you're reading
vicarious experience and having a strong
learning signal through interaction now
that actually there's a bit of luck
because it's the opportunity to to do
what you're doing
um I mean similarly anyone who goes out
there and makes a startup even if it
fails you will learn more doing that
than reading a thousand books absolutely
agree like genuinely like one one of the
number one things I love to see on
people's CVS is failed startups it
doesn't matter if they succeed or not
the fact that they tried they went out
at the interacting with reality will
give them so many bits of evidence so
many skills so much now they cannot be
gained other ways it's like it's so
impactful yeah yeah exactly
so you've thrown yourself into the fire
and it's changed it yeah it has and it
really has but for the better it feels
like they've been sharpened you know it
feels like I've been you know I've been
I've become more where I was heading
rather than like I'm a different person
now it's like I like to think that like
every version of me throughout time if
they could like look forward to me now
they would still recognize me we would
disagree and they'd be confused about
some of the things I believe and some of
the things I do but we would recognize
each other you know we would we would
see that we're still the same person and
we've and I think that's a even so I'm
quite different from younger me in many
ways and I have some very different
opinions and some very different views
in reality yeah
let's talk about your your learning rate
though so if if for example we
discovered over the next five years that
you know AGI doesn't happen in the way
that you think it does
how much of your identity is tied up in
in this current kind of Journey
I mean ideally zero
like ultimately my goal is the only
thing I really care about is to make a
good future for mankind is to make
everyone happy the fundamental thing I
care about is that I don't want people
to suffer anymore no one that's all it
is and where does that come from
you know you can pick your own
orthogonality you know all orthogonal
goals right I just really don't like
people suffering I really really don't
like it and I want to stop and I'm going
to make it stop and
I want things to be nice I want people
to be happy I see um
there's just a kid this was like um
it's very silly it's uh it's very silly
but it's like a very autistic thing it's
like this like as a kid when I was like
I don't know
eight or nine or something I would like
uh have I remember having newspaper and
I read this newspaper and I haven't
really read a newspaper before like
never really actively
and I read some article I don't know
what it was about it was something like
pretty boring it was like
I don't know it's like like a car
accident happened and like someone like
got hurt or something and then and just
it just like hit I was like I like put
myself into the scenario and like oh
this poor woman like oh my God like
she's gonna lose her job and like she's
in pain and like oh she has a small
daughter and like oh no what are the
daughter thinks she's gonna be scared of
cars for the rest of her life like oh my
God like it was a very small thing it
was very very small but then I noticed
if I put just the littlest bit of
creativity into like imagining actually
the suffering and then it's this hate me
that this was everywhere there's
everything
from the smallest things we do every
single day you know every heartbreak
every you know failed missed opportunity
every miscommunication every you know
accident every tragedy it's just like
it's just so horrific it's just the true
like the teenager had this theory that
like every every drama can be equally or
better Rewritten as a horror I was I
love horror movies it was always my
favorite I had this obsession with
things that frightened me and I found
that I really quickly got super numb to
like monster movies or like aliens or
whatever it's because it's like this is
a monster right you know kills you or
whatever like but it's like it's not
real you know it's like it's like kind
of fun it's fun if you have some like
crazy creepy monster that you know you
know skins the protagonists alive and
like how isn't that kind of like oh oh
it's like gross you know it's like kind
of fun
but the one that really got me like the
horror movies that like still stuck with
me always the ones that are the least
abnormal it was always just like
something tragic happened just like
someone had a terrible life and their
parents abused them and they commit
suicide those are the ones that really
stuck to me because those are real and
this happens to people all the
time and I feel like
not wanting that is just obvious I think
everyone wants those things to stop
and I had this weird experience as a kid
is I would like it was obvious to me
like oh I have to cure aging of course
because like you know look at all these
people are getting old and it hurts
they're sad and it's bad and they die
and when people die that's sad so I'm
just gonna so we just have to not do
that anymore
and when I would bring this to people
they would look at me like I'm crazy
they'd be like well no actually aging is
good it Gives Life Meaning like what the
hell are you talking about like what no
people are sad sad is bad so in a sense
I always was a bit of like just this
like so this is what I really focused on
like you know AI or like anti-aging or
like whatever are all instrumental all
my full my full identities I want people
to not be sad anymore
okay because because two things jump out
at me there first of all I'm I'm
I guess I'm I'm pleased and and a little
bit surprised just the the the empathy
that you feel at a cellular level and
most people would be surprised by that
because you were just talking about like
um you know again not to essentialize
rationalists but you kind of think of
them as being slightly autistic and low
on empathy and that's a surprise because
you're very high on empathy so I would
actually push back against that okay I'm
gonna push that against that I think
after autistic people not all of them
but many I think you if you selected for
the highest empathy individuals most of
them will be autistic really and so the
reason I think this is because so we can
talk about autism and my theory I always
get to theory of autism but longer but
the reason for this is I think that a
lot of things that holds people back
from to empathy is exactly these things
I was talking about is that people
Galaxy brain themselves they add in all
this complexity these like social roles
like kids often are very empathetic but
then they're taught they're not supposed
to care or you're or you learn to not
care or things are so horrible terrible
things happen and learn not to care or
you just follow your social rules like
in in your culture maybe there's this
you know your tribe is suffering is bad
but the other tribe well they suffer as
good actually so you shouldn't worry
about that and it takes the like um it's
like true just autistic just like
disregard of social norms and like like
taking things seriously it's like
actually see I remember I talked to
someone know about this and uh I talked
to them like as a kid I was obsessed
with like empathy and like making the
world a better place and more people to
hurt and and she was like well yeah yes
and I I see that I'm definitely telling
you is like this is what makes you so
human you know this empathy like no no
no no no no you're very wrong empathy is
very not human
a very very empathetic creature is an
alien really really moral people really
moral people do not look like
charismatic Hollywood star no they're
weird aliens they're weird
autistic aliens they get obsessed and
they write massive papers about
simulated souls in the the far future
universe and how we can maximize the
long-termism that's what Maxim empathy
actually looks like if you actually
maximize your utility function for
empathy what you get is people like
Bostrom and Eleazar they look like
aliens because it's really weird and
humans are usually not like this so this
is a fascinating Point first of all I
want to get to that in a second but
would you describe yourself as a
transhumanist you can describe me that
way but I don't associate with the
movement interesting because it sounds
quite similar but I guess um maybe I've
been thinking about this the wrong way
but what you're describing it because I
had assumed that it was almost like a
pathology of the lack of empathy to kind
of make up for it in a very technical
way and I would say what you're
describing you know we were saying
earlier about
um our software is buggy right and we
need to fix it and what you're talking
about is a very technical form of
empathy which most people can't
can't really feel in the same way yep if
you really want to see who if I had to
pick the most empathetic man to ever
live it'll be Brian tomasic he's a he's
an author he wrote a bunch of essays and
they're the weirdest most inhuman alien
you're ever read in your life most
people read this and will actually
conclude that you make the most evil man
to ever live for example he thinks
deforestation is good and the reason he
thinks this forestation is good is
because it kills lots of animals and
because that's good because those
animals in nature would have suffered
because they'll be like sick and they'll
be eaten and killed so if we just kill
them and like pave over it there'll be
less animals that experience less
suffering and then we can put humans
there and they suffer less so we can
have you know like some other like pets
that are not suffering you have to be an
alien to come up with this I like but
like this is what Matt you know dial up
all the way of empathy actually looks
like it does not look very human at all
it looks really really weird so
the Paradox is that a lot of people we
won't say who they are these are people
who have let's say sensory empathy and
they don't recognize what you're doing
as empathy they don't understand it yep
what would you say to them
it's very different it's um the uh it's
I think a lot of people have sensory
empathy don't actually take empathy
seriously as a concept is that they're
not optimizers they're not maximizing
what they're
they're proxy they have a heuristic they
have a feeling they have a thing which
is
associated with that it is um correlated
with what we were empathy but it's not
the maxim so this is like like Brian
tomasik is the example of like it was
like the human equivalent of a paperclip
maximizer for empathy is like humans
would be like oh it's so silly why would
the paper clip maximizer only on paper
clips now like well why is Brian temasek
only want empathy you know why is Brian
Tomasek only want to reduce suffering
this is what it looks like if you have a
very intelligent system if an optimizer
it will go to really weird extremes most
humans are not optimizers the state of
optimizing of electron actually trying
your hardest to it to maximize a goal is
actually not how most humans work a
friend of mine had a very cynical uh
take he said most humans are like
wind-up toys they optimize for end steps
and then they halt it doesn't matter
where they hold that's as far as they go
and they don't even feel the obligation
to have to go further than this it's
actually very unnatural for humans to
really try to go as many steps as they
can go and that's why when people do try
to do this they can often achieve looks
like Supernatural amounts of things
because most people don't really try
they don't go for arbitrary amount of
steps they go so many steps and with
empathy you know you're this many steps
like you know okay you know my family
yeah sure you know my neighbors sure
cool um my country sure this other
country don't like um okay let's you
know slow slow down slow down slow down
you know that's what end steps of
optimization looks like rather than
arbitrary access arbitrary step says
okay other countries yeah absolutely All
Humans yeah absolutely animals yeah sure
at plants probably you know that's
that's what
optimization looks like it gets humans
exist in a very small regime
and this applies to everything it
applies to our abilities applies to our
thoughts our emotions it applies to
everything humans are very bounded and
this is one of the things why AI is
going to be very different it's going to
look way more like Brian tomasik than it
is going to look like you and me
necessarily it's going to look like a
like systems that take
these things and bring them to such
extremes and are willing to go so far
because that's how we build them you
know yeah I mean I agree so I mean this
is this is moral status it it decays
exponentially with time and space I mean
even the way that we understand
causality is is very flawed you know
like look at road traffic accidents for
example you know it's not not easy
sometimes to assign who's morally
accountable but
um what are the limits then because if
you take this to the nth degree
surely you can be Fooled by Randomness
and you can
um it almost becomes pathological you
know you might do things which are
apparently extreme
right as I said Brian damaso thinks we
should kill all animals
and I disagree with him on that but his
reasoning is sound his reasoning is
completely sound given his objectives
given what he believes and is objective
and you say pathological yeah Ryan
recently stopped writing because he
basically had a mental breakdown and
said you just can't handle it anymore
he's gonna live in a farm alone with his
parents and not talk to anyone ever
again
so yes this is a very unnatural and a
very non-human state to be in and you
know God bless my man Brian tomasik even
if I strongly disagree with him and I
think if we implemented his ethics that
would be a moral catastrophe
um he actually tried he actually really
tried to do as much good as possible he
really really tried he has an essay
which is can electrons suffer
he really tried that's what really
trying looks like he wanted to reduce
suffering and he went all the way
and he was very mentally ill obviously
like this man obviously had you only go
that far if you're very ill like you
have to be very neurotypical to be
capable of this
and obviously I don't agree I'm not Ryan
and I don't think we should kill all
animals anyway I don't think we should
you know and all the other some of the
things but clearly there is
I also think that many other humans are
not sufficiently empathetic so because
like for example if I tell people hey I
think people should not die they're like
no no it's it's normal it's it's the
correct thing I'm like man
you don't even take your empathy
seriously you don't actually take the
reduction of empathy seriously like
death is bad people dying is sad we
should just not do that I know I mean
what worries me because you could you
could use a similar argumentation to
justify the actions of of the Unabomber
for example or a similar You could argue
basically because there's a theme to our
conversation which is that
um our thinking is anthropomorphic and
it's problematic so we should dehumanize
our thinking and be more rational and
then you get to a stage that appears to
an external Observer like nihilism like
for example I can say if all humans I
think this is a thought experiment
philosophy if all humans died in their
sleep painlessly tonight it would kind
of reduce the suffering in the world
therefore let's do it yep that just
seems It's un it's unimaginable
to most people yes it is a completely
reasonable argument given the premises
if you accept the premises it is a
reasonable argument I just don't accept
the premises like I mean LOL I'm not a
consequentialist I'm not a negative
utilitarian like if you're a negative
utilitarian that yes that argument makes
perfect sense I'm not and I don't claim
to be I have the anthological principles
or my data logic principles says I don't
kill all humans I don't have a
justification for that like a
sufficiently intelligent alien or Brian
or whatever can give me an argument that
should convince me to kill all humans
I'm not going to do it but that is a
deontological commitment that is what I
mean that's what it means to not be a
consequentialist there are
consequentialists you have to do these
things you have to be capable of doing
these things and then if you're a
consequentialist who is also human you
get people like the Unabomber who just
dumb like sorry Ted but like is mean
other than being cruel and just like you
know horrific
it was just stupid like if his stated
goals were what he described
how did he expect this plan to actually
achieve that like La Mao it's like it's
like the like you know
pseudorrationalists who are like oh to
stop AGI we should bomb Taiwan I'm like
man even if you did that
what exactly is your thinking of things
that plan would actually work like are
you insane
so there's there's the part of like
consequentialism can lead you to bad
outcomes and like
I mean so there's the the The Cheeky
answer is is that well if you did it
right no it wouldn't if you were good at
consequentialism and there was a bad
option you just wouldn't pick it like
obviously obviously so but then there's
the other thing which is like a
proximate consequentialism where if you
have a human who's trying to reason
consequently over a space they can't
reason over yes they're gonna make
mistakes and in that process those
mistakes can be like arbitrarily bad
from a different perspective awesome
okay what else do you want to talk about
I've already talked about conjunction
much or what I've worked at all really
tell me about I'd love to talk about it
more so it's been it's been a while
right at conjecture and you know we're
about 18 people now we do a lot of
interesting things uh we're in we're a
bit of an unusual company
um where
like I've been talking about at heart
what I really want what we want to do is
solve the alignment problem and you know
create a good future for them
make things well but we're also very
pragmatic in that a research is
expensive and you need you need to pay
people salaries and you compute and so
on so we also do a certain amount of
product work so we also build like AI
products that are not pushing the state
of the art because we consider that it
should be dangerous but use the kind of
creativity and like you know also
technology that already exists to make
useful applications so we're currently
we're kind of like iterating through
like lots and lots of different ideas
kind of really quickly like doing
sprints and like finding things you know
there if people are I hope people be
interested in trying our various
products once they hit the market and
see if they're any good or not could you
give us any hints on what you're
developing So currently we're just we're
developing a useful uh meeting notes
tool just a simple like you know
transcription tool that you know it's
like summarize
speaker detection stuff oh similar to
I'm doing yes yeah very similar we're
not sure if this is going to be our
forever tool we're we're sprinting I'm
trying a bunch of different tools I
actually find the first tool built so it
was very funny we had this great vision
for this really cool complex writing
assistant tool and we built it and then
we found it was just way too complicated
for users and we're like damn like
people just don't understand this tool
it's too complicated yeah so we kind of
like pivot away from that and we have a
bunch of other ideas so things were
going there but ultimately what we
really care about is we think that you
know AGI is coming soon very powerful
systems that are coming we need to
really Advance our Theory our
understanding our ability to align these
systems
we um so we do a lot of interpretability
work like mechanistic interpretability
work we do a bunch of other work I am
very soon probably by the time this
podcast comes out it'll be open I'll
have uh publish my personal research
agenda which has been secret for quite a
while
um but I want to publish it so a lot of
people can like critique it and like
comment on it so hopefully by the time
this this podcast is out you can go take
give it a look and tell me I'm crazy
um uh it's but yeah it's it's been a
wild ride and we also do a lot of work
on trying to understand trying to work
on coordination and working with other
people to basically just hard I want
other people to see this problem is real
it is a technical problem it is not a
pro it was very funny I was in Brussels
I'm talking to politicians and one of
them kind of like kind of like
sneeringly noticed that I was like on
the on these like AGI people like oh so
you believe in this like Singularity
thing huh and now I was like I think
whether Singularity exists or not just a
purely technical question about reality
and independent of my personal
philosophical or religious beliefs and
he was like good point
and that's kind of the the the message I
I try to push to people is that these
questions are fundamentally scientific
in nature
um there is also hard philosophical
questions but whether these strums exist
whether AGI is possible whether you know
alignment is hard or not or like mostly
tactical questions and I think I want to
also kind of question people I think
alignment is not the kind of problem is
not good solved by default like there
are in most worlds if you don't try it
just doesn't get solved and just keep
building stronger and stronger systems
which I slowly you know drift away from
what you exactly and then eventually
just something weird happens and then
we're suddenly stuck in some World which
we don't like and there's no way out you
know it doesn't have to be all people
even die I mean like you could also just
be we get stuck in some kind of like you
know corporate you know advertisement
hellscape forever and just we can't
escape because all the governments are
one AI now and we're just stuck you know
that's also a possible outcome so
building software products is really
difficult it requires a different
culture a different mindset different
types of people lots of challenges and
so on and it feels basically orthogonal
to to the alignment work that you're
doing
and so now you have to hire different
types of people divide your effort and
resources and so on how do you wrestle
with that is it really is a very hard
problem it's been less hard and practice
than expected it to be so I do like this
is the original sin of conjecture the
original sin is that we have to divide
our attention to certain degree but
we're just like pragmatic about it I
talked earlier about how I've become
more tolerant of uh of um tension and
the word tension was like specifically
chosen because this is a great example
of tension this is like cognitive
dissonance there's tension here and
at first I was like I was I tried to
like you know bend over backwards to
remove this tension but now I'm just
like oh no there is a tension here and
I'm just gonna accept that like this is
just a cost I'm willing to pay of course
if some you know benevolent billionaire
watching this show would like to just
you know shower us with sufficient fun
that we can just focus fully on our
research and don't have to focus on
product
please give me a call but I don't expect
us to live in that world I I expect us
to live in a world where if you need
billions say to do Cutting Edge research
and to hire enough researchers and to do
lobbying and like who knows what else is
necessary right whatever is necessary to
solve this problem then we see and like
products and like in this coming AI you
know tsunami that I expect is just the
most effective way to raise the
necessary resource in a way it's a form
of instrumental convergence yes it's yes
I have undergone instrumental
convergence in the sense that I don't
care about money for its own sake I care
about you know improving people's lives
it makes people happy and like you know
you know all these things but
instrumentally to achieve those goals
you need money you need friends you need
yeah influence you need power you know
you need to do these things and so I
just do those it stopped because I enjoy
them I don't it's just part of the job
interesting because I want to unpick a
little bit from an investors care about
returns yep and they will see that you
have I mean you know my co-founders it
really pisses them off that I do so much
stuff on mlst they think I'm obsessed
with mlst and I think that it's hugely
beneficial for our business as well and
I I know it will go somewhere
interesting I know it's enriching and
it's magical in lots of different ways
and I would imagine you have the same
thought about the alignment work that
even though they seem orthogonal
actually they're not oh of course
absolutely I mean ultimately it's
the ultimate problem it is the best
problem you know it is the thing that
needs to be solved you solve alignment
you solve everything you know you get
you good end you know you shake hands GG
well played you know and so we did it we
did it boys you know you can build
everything you once we get AGI it's it
resolvable if we solve alignment you get
everything you can build everything read
all the most valuable products you can
cure all diseases you can you know you
know bring World Peace have everyone you
know negotiate superhumanly well and
like be friends with each other you can
achieve you know every product will
ultimately be bottlenecked every every
goal you want to achieve will be bottom
that by control once intelligence and
power is no longer limiting factor
currently our systems are still limited
by their power and their intelligence
but more and more the bottleneck is
going to be our ability to control them
and we expect and we are currently
observing in our opinion that people are
vastly under estimating this
bottlenecked and that this bottleneck
might be so critical that you know it
caused catastrophe it is an adult
unresolved but also if you just want
value you know and ultimately we want
value right we want not just like you
know value in the abstract things but in
the practical sense of like things that
people like and things that make people
happy you know you know sure if you
develop a drug that cures cancer that
will make you a lot of money but also it
cures cancer that's great like
nice awesome so for that you need to
solve the alignment problem and so you
know it's just kind of in a
in a world I think where people maybe
had the same had more of the like
autistic you know straightforwardness
that I do I think a lot of people would
just fund that and wouldn't need the
short-term returns but I'm practical and
that I'm just like understand that's
just not how the world works it's
actually really interesting thing this
is another thing I learned over the last
year is that the biggest bottleneck on
doing great things to my surprise is
often trust and it sounds so banal that
when I first thought about this or when
I was first told this by a friend of
mine I felt I thought he was like no I
like Renault resources or intelligence
or like whatever but more and more I
realize that like no man it's so hard to
get like people to truly actually trust
each other and not get scammed like if
you can find a way to like 100 like
check that someone's not a scammer and
they you can trust them completely like
imagine what would be possible this is
actually one of my uh schizo things if I
if I wasn't working on AI if I thought
AI was further away and I wanted to save
the world I would probably work on mind
reading technology and the reason I
would do that is is because it'll allow
you to coordinate you could check for
liars and then everyone could you could
just have perfect honesty and people
could you could have you could have
trustworthy collaboration that cannot be
broken
of course it practiced that would
probably lead to dystopia but so I
wouldn't actually probably build this
but it is a funny it's a fun sci-fi
Vision to think about
where everyone want to think of mine you
know mind reading you first think of
dystopia but then also Imagine you could
have your politicians be checked that
they never lie to their constituents and
you can check that if someone signs a
contract that they will never break the
contract and you can like enforce this
if you could do this man the level of
coordination the level of like trust you
could build in an efficient organization
in an efficient organization in an
efficient group an efficient Society I
think you could uh I think you could get
a lot out of that probably not actually
possible but it's funny to think about
it yeah and ironically another form of
alignment but yeah trust trust makes the
world go round even when I invite guests
onto mlst they'll say yes if they trust
that I'll give them a good interview
okay so we we have
um you know like a we have a concept of
status in our mind and who we trust and
a lot of it actually is is a theory of
mind it's it's it's we predict how other
people will behave in in certain
situations yep yep absolutely correct
yeah interesting okay so can you speak
to specifically the the work that you've
been doing I can't speak to the work
specifically that I personally have been
doing at this time yeah unfortunately
um
anything that you've published I talked
about six other people who are not me
have published at the company okay my I
personally have not published very much
okay okay uh we have
um I think the most interesting work
scientifically is the interpretability
work we've done so we have a number of
posts which I I'm not going to go to the
details now but are worth reading where
we've just been doing lots of
interesting experiments trying to like
iterate on
um trying to understand language models
how they work internally neural networks
and stuff mostly small things were just
kind of like been working very quickly
trying many things
um
there is also a so this is something I
think a lot of people won't recognize as
something very valuable but I think is
super exciting which is so we're a very
weird company for one we have an
epistemology team which is a very weird
thing for a stars and everyone thinks
we're crazy for this and I keep talking
no no no no like like this is where I
spend my crazy points on because like I
we we've you know cut on epistemology
earlier today but I think epistemology
doing it right is actually the most
powerful like meta skill you can have of
course most people just don't do it
right like my in my opinion if you were
good at like good philosophy should make
you stronger being a great philosopher
should make you better at everything you
know you should be better at your job
you should be better at your
relationships you should be better at
understanding science you should be
better at everything of course
unfortunately that's not how most
philosophy is done it's actually really
sad that I feel like a lot of people
don't even expect philosophy should be
useful
I don't know how it got to this point
but like if for me you know if you're
the greatest philosopher to ever live
you should be good at everything you
should be a complete polymath genius but
that's unfortunately not how things
really are in practice does that mean
that you have hired knowledge engineers
in a way yes that's what do they do
that's a great question and they do some
things they can't talk about some things
that will be published so they've done
some things that are like pretty you
know standard philosophy stuff like
trying to like understand how science is
done like in the past how was science
done why how can these be applied
alignment how why is it like hard
there's a pretty good post that Adam
who's the head of our
epistemology team wrote called
epistemological vigilance for alignment
where he talks about the uh I I had a
hand in that post as well and we talked
a lot about how why is alignment
particularly difficult like why is it
different from physics a lot of people
look at physics and I see physics it's
like high status science like well oh
look we solved quantum physics so like
surely like we can solve any problem but
like no quantum physics is actually a
very easy problem epistemologically
speaking compared to many other problems
like there's so many ways in which
physics is kind of like the easiest
science like you have like these like
repeatable experiments you can do you
have lots of data you have like these
like simplified systems you have like
you just like ignore second order
correlations like all these reasons that
don't apply to like harder so like what
a really hard Sciences are things like
predict the stock market that's hard
because it's adversarial like you
interacting with the system makes it
resist you that is very hard to study
and we do not have good epistemology of
how to study adversarial systems or
chaotic systems chaotic systems are kind
of like a more General class of
adversarial systems adversarials are
like a particularly bad system in this
regard and yeah Express for example AGI
to be an Ascent adversarial and chaotic
and various other properties
so that's a lot of stuff they've been
doing
um they also are writing a sequence of
posts which I think are really really
great and I really recommend you they're
very short I recommend we're called
building blocks which is just like one
page each kind of explaining a very
simple like philosophical idea or like a
very simple like piece of advice or a
very simple like idea of like how to
think better or like optimize better the
long-term goal is
as I've said earlier that like being an
Optimizer is an unnatural thing for
human to be like most people are not
optimizers and that's really bad because
we need optimizers to actually solve
hard problems like like you know if you
want to be the best at science or you
want to solve the hardest problem you
have to be an optimized you know
um and
I think a lot of it can be taught
actually
um I think learning to be an optimized
the thing you can learn I've learned a
much more how to be an Optimizer than I
have in the past I'm much better at just
like accomplishing arbitrary goals
um which is an interesting state to be
in and the building block Series has a
bunch of like are like distilled things
that we've found that have like helped
us improve This and like raise a Sandy
water line like help people make more
reasonable epistemological decisions and
thinkings they're also working some
other stuff that I can't currently
talking about but yeah it's very weird
it's a big bet and like a lot of people
think I'm crazy for doing it but you
know we'll see fascinating I think I did
read the blog post about the
interpretability on the language model
and and I don't I don't want to
trivialize it in any way but it was
something along the lines of what if it
is an AGI and we don't know is that is
that fair summarization
um we don't have a single post about
that specifically uh we have a few posts
of like very talking about various
topics that I'm not sure exactly what
you're trying to talk about you might be
talking about I'm not sure exactly which
one you're talking about maybe I'm
misremembering but I think it was
something along the lines of what if
it's
um deceiving us oh yes how to defeat
mind readers right okay yeah Ali wrote
that post that's one of the posts that
one of our researchers has written we've
written a whole bunch of these but okay
and yeah that's an interesting one
whereas like you know uh how could a
system that is trying to trick us trick
us and there's a lot of ways there's
many many ways they can trick us so that
was more of a brainstorming post okay
we've also done some technical work
we've had like um like polytopes we have
one on the SVD directions are very
interpretable in Transformer models a
few other posts like this most of them
are quite sure like less than the paper
they're like we we focused more on like
producing small interesting posts and
like optimizing more for like small
interesting pieces of information rather
than trying to like produce massive
papers that take six months to write
and we're getting much faster at that
too yeah so that's kind of like more the
direction of like where the village is
currently heading of course the
long-term vision is developed much
better interpretability theories and
tools and methods yeah because that's a
great example we know we were talking
earlier about that creative insight and
most people would not think for a second
that let's say GPT I mean you said when
we spoke last time uh we had we had
dinner out and you know there was that
refrigerator token
um sometimes the characters in in the
simulation become self-aware that
they're in a simulation or in the case
that you just spoke about maybe
something like gpt3 is actually trying
to deceive us and it's the nature of it
is actually different to what we think
it is and that's something that most
people just wouldn't have the
imagination to come up with that yep yep
it's um it's very true this is a this is
another classic in the alignment world
is that it's kind of like futurist
whack-a-mole where the usual way this
game this this happens is the futurist
says um hey I think you know AGI you
know do some like crazy things and like
things we can't understand or predict
and then the interlocutor will be like
well okay name one thing and then they
name a thing and like oh no that's
actually irrelevant because actually
that can be fixed using this and then
and then like well yeah sure but what
about you know scenario two and like oh
okay yeah but like we could have done
this other thing to solve that but then
and then the future at some point it's
like don't you see the problem you
didn't think of one or two before I
pointed out to you yeah but I could fix
it once you pointed out like no no the
generalized form of this is that a
sufficiently intelligent system will
come up with even more things than
neither you nor me can come up with yeah
this is a it's very funny how often I
run into this exact scenario or I I like
give people us like people ask me for a
scenario and I'm like fine here's the
scenario and they're like oh okay and
while I'm not worried anymore because I
could take that one and then they don't
generalize so the general case like okay
but you didn't come up with it either so
what are all the other things you're not
coming up with if you're dealing with a
system that's smarter than you you
should just expect it can trick you even
if you can't come up with how it can
trick you you should just assume there
is something you can do that can trick
you yeah amazing Connor this has been
great um what are your plans for
Christmas and and the New Year heading
home to my family I haven't seen them in
a long time because they're going to
spend some time in Germany and then I'm
gonna come back to London with my German
friends in Tao and we're going to
celebrate New Year's here so really
looking forward to that advising
advising uh Connally here it's been an
absolute honor thank you so much for
joining us thanks so much Tim
cool